want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation
from john assaraf enjoy
we developed our company at praxis and
we developed a process
called the 5r process and the first
r stands for recognize
your thought patterns recognize your
emotions recognize your behaviors
and ask yourself are they going to move
me towards what i want
or away from what i want okay so you
don't you don't try to change anything
just ask yourself you recognize just
become more
aware and then
instead of reacting to what you don't
like
you learn how to respond that's the
second r
so recognize then respond hmm
can i change this can i change the
meaning of this can i change the emotion
of this can i change
you know anything about this that is
destructive
and the answer is yes the third part
is to reframe anything that doesn't work
for you
so whether it's a person a situation a
circumstance
how can you reframe it look at it from a
different
point of view so that it doesn't have
the same meaning anymore
and one of the things that we know is
the meaning that we give
anything determines how we feel about it
yes the meaning we give it nothing has a
meaning
independent of our own thoughts and
meanings
so can we reframe something look at it a
different way
emotionalize it a different way so that
we can use it
as opposed to it using us
the fourth part is when we're feeling a
negative or destructive emotion
can we through breathing exercises
through reframing release that emotion
because every
emotion is a wave so there are
six main emotions that we have there are
sub emotions as well but we feel fear
anger sadness happiness disgust etc
and those cause us to feel a certain way
so
is there a way for us to release the
unpleasant emotions there's not
good or bad emotions they're pleasant
or unpleasant yeah and that is comes
from directly from one of my dear
friends dr joan rosenberg who's an
emotional mastery expert
wow and and so when you think about is
this
emotion pleasant yes okay good let's do
more of that
is this emotion unpleasant okay well
what's causing it usually it's
what's causing is something from my past
that is telling me that whatever is
happening
maybe i can reproduce it well if it's if
it's a
if it's a unpleasant emotion usually
it's a memory from the past
versus reality and so when you learn
that emotions last 90 seconds to a
minute and 20 seconds
two minutes and if you just observe it
and feel the emotion it's like a wave
feel the emotion without getting into
the reaction
of the emotion observe it
now you're in control of the emotion now
you're learning to surf the wave
instead of being hit by the wave and
then the fifth part is now
to retrain your brain so
recognize respond
reframe release and now i want to
retrain my brain
to have a different thought pattern a
different emotional response and a
different
behavior so that i change the pattern in
my brain so it doesn't happen again
and if you do that one time five times
10 times 20 times
the same thought or the same emotion or
the same circumstance won't have the
same power
to cause you to freeze or run away or
fight
now we're starting to get in control
yeah it's great
[Music]
of our own brains our own emotions and
now we can start to use the spiritual
side of our being the higher side of our
being
to move towards the greatness that i
think is within every human being
setting goals is an intellectual and
imagined exercise
that your conscious brain right i'm
going to show you one of the little
brains today
from the city heart my house your
conscious brain
left prefrontal cortex specifically
where you get to choose
what is it you would love to have your
life be like
what is the imagination you know of the
ideal life that you'd like he says
everybody could do that he says but
achieving
goals happens as a result
of having the right
perceptions habits attitudes
at the non-conscious level
where all of the habits reside part of
the hippocampus part of your brain
that drives your automatic behavior
day in and day out is
what is going to determine whether you
achieve those goals or not he says
using willpower
to achieve goals is like using
gun powder it's just a starter
using resilience or using your
imagination
those are all really good conscious
abilities that
anybody can use he says but if you don't
develop the habits at the non-conscious
level which
include your self-image for how you see
your life
you're never going to achieve those
goals
one of the things that i was taught
playing sports
was repetition is the mother of
skill repetition is the mother of skill
which is
another lesson that i learned at a very
young age
why does any piano coach
guitar coach
coach for sports have their students
repeat drills over and over and over and
over again whether
it's layups or free throws or playing
you know certain chords on the guitar or
on the piano
why is repetition so important
the answer is because when you repeat
a pattern over and over and over again
whether it's
a language pattern an emotional pattern
or a behavioral pattern
when you repeat it over and over and
over and over again
20 times 50 times 100 times 200 times
500 times a thousand times
you actually are creating patterns in
the brain
that initially go from being conscious
patterns patterns that require
effort and intention and attention your
conscious mind
to patterns that become non-conscious
that require
less energy and less attention because
it's been repeated so many times it
becomes second nature
so you have to use intrinsic and
extrinsic motivation so you have to
start everybody off well why is it
important for you to be able to develop
these new beliefs
like what would your life be like if you
had them right now
what would your family life be like you
have to give them
a benefit that's greater than the switch
cost
that's interesting right so the switch
cost
is something that our brain resists the
only human that likes change is a wet
baby
every other human being is resistant to
it because
safety first and homeostasis and energy
conservation
so we are biologically wired not to want
to change
so we have to deliberately coax the
brain
into motivational reasons emotional
reasons
you have to have intrinsic reason why
must you do this and so you can use
pain as a frame as well so if you don't
then
are you okay with your life being like
this at this age in five years and 10
years and 20 years
and if you're okay with that then you're
not a candidate for change
but if you're committed to letting go of
the old so you can create the new
and you create motivations every day
that's where the power is remember
earlier progress not perfection
so anybody can do one minute or
or 10 seconds so if you can start to
formulate a habit a daily habit a weekly
habit
it doesn't matter how long it is if you
can
create that space in your brain that on
this day
at this time this is what i do and you
do that repeatedly
that becomes a habit and it takes those
66 days or so for a simple habit
that you have to consciously do to then
the habit doing you
hey this is john assaraf and do you love
good books i love to read because
there's so much
wisdom in books you get to take somebody
else's knowledge
skills research pay 15 20 bucks
and you learn so much now i'm reading
this
awesome book called built to serve find
your purpose and become the leader you
were born to be and one of my
new friends really smart guy really
great guy who serves a lot of people
evan carmichael
wrote it and i'm going to read a little
bit from
chapter number one and
i love this piece and maybe it's because
i just watched
the series on tv on michael jordan the
last dance which is really great by the
way also
one of the things he says here is
everybody has
michael jordan talent
at something everybody has a michael
jordan talent at something you just
haven't found it yet
or you have and you don't believe
in yourself enough to go all in
to go all in right and you're a genius i
believe you're a genius
and so does he you're amazing you were
not meant to live
a photocopy of someone else's life
you were not created to wake up and do
work that is below your capabilities
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
and you need to uncover exactly what
your purpose is
and how you can serve and use the serve
so
lots of pearls and gems and motivational
pieces
pickup built to serve evan carmichael
rising star the first thing that you
have to ask
is what are your highest values
so for me for example my number one
highest value is god
my number two value is my health my
number three value is my family
my number four value is contribution to
the lives of others my
number fifth value is fun so every day
when i wake up i think about
what am i doing today to connect with
god for me
just for me it doesn't have to be you
know it's not religious it's just for me
then what do i need to do every day to
make sure that i'm healthy
what i need to do every day to make sure
that my family and my dear close friends
are part of my family
that i have the relationship that's rich
then
contribution how do i use my my passion
my gifts my
my stories my things i've not done well
things i have done
how do i share that with the world and
in doing that
i feel good and then i have to have fun
and so if i do those five things every
day
then at the end of every day i've had a
great day
and if you have a lot of great days then
you end up with a really great life
and that doesn't mean that you don't
have ups and downs and things that don't
work and
trouble that happens and things that
come up but if you keep your
focus on what's important
then the rest of the stuff is really
inconsequential
and there isn't a hundred different
things you have to do
there's two or three things in each one
of the areas that's important to you
when you do those every day
you're so far ahead of the curve so when
i wake up in the morning
the first thing i do is i do a gratitude
exercise where i ask myself
usually in bed what am i most grateful
for today
and usually you know i'm grateful for my
health i'm grateful for my wife i'm
grateful for my children i'm grateful
for to be alive i'm grateful
you know for my family i'm grateful to
to have experiences and you do you do
that
eyes closed yeah i do that eyes closed
and
while i while i think about that i feel
it
and so the feeling starts every day with
a great feeling
i start every day with a great feeling
do you visualize some
things you like your children or do you
talk to yourself how do you do that yeah
i have an internal dialogue
i see images of the things that i'm
thinking about
and that just takes me two minutes just
two minutes
when i wake up and then i go to exercise
to take care of my body
how long um usually one hour to an hour
and 15 minutes every day
and so i do a variety of different
things i hike
i bike i work on aerobics i work on
strength i work with weights i do
whatever it is i just do it to give my
body the physical exercise
then as soon as i finish my exercise in
my gym
when i run a half an hour an hour 15
minutes at the most
so then in my gym i have uh two things i
have a vision board which is my dream
board for my
you are known for that yes so i have my
vision board
for my my physique and my body and my
health
but then i also have in in my gym
something called an achieved board
okay so after i achieved some of the
things that i achieved
best in the future no achieved in the
past yes so past
you have the past and the future
so i have in my in my gym in my home gym
i have a
like a place where i sit and before i
start my meditation
i look at my vision board from the past
okay so i get connected to the different
things that i've been able to achieve
and i remember every day
when i set my mind and my focus to
achieving goals
i can achieve all of my goals but what i
also do
is i reinforce most people focus on
what's not working this isn't going well
this didn't work
i want to remind myself every day
of look how many things i was able to
accomplish
by being clear by being passionate by
using these rituals
so before i go into my meditation which
is with my eyes closed
i look at my achieved board i get
emotionally
associated with it to remind myself that
when i
set my mind to achieve something i
can do it and then i look across
because i have a mirror in the gym and i
look across
and i say i love you just the way you
are and i said
i accept you just the way you are with
all of your
skills and passion and faults and
insecurities and doubts and fears
i accept you just the way you are
and i smile and then i close my eyes
and i do about a 15-minute meditation
wow and in my meditation sometimes i
have
no thoughts where i'm just one with the
universe and everything
other times i'll just follow my thoughts
and i'll just pay attention be mindful
of where are they going this morning
where are they going today
so i'll follow my thoughts and i'll just
follow them
other times i'll follow a thought and
say release that one
and follow another thought and say
release that one so i'm teaching my
brain that i'm in control
of my brain the more you can create
success rituals processes and systems
daily success rituals to
activate your motivational centers
your um emotional centers
and behaviors the more you can create
daily rituals of how you start a day
how you deal with stress during the day
how you plan your day how you evaluate
your day
how you follow through to the end of the
day in a process that puts you in a
cycle of success
the easier it becomes to achieve success
and to make that
the default mode of the brain once you
understand that the power center
is right within you and you learn how to
just use the tools a little bit better
we've got the most powerful three pound
tool in the world
with no user's manual
and and so we teach people here's the
latest research here's how you can apply
to your life be healthier happier make
more money
get a better job get a raise start your
business and do better by retraining
your brain
to be totally and aligned with your
goals and dreams and like in
learning how do i stay focused how do i
stay motivated
how do i stay on track how do i develop
the habits that will empower me and how
do i do the things that
inspire me instead of the things that
expire me what happened for me
personally when i was a
a teen between age of 13 to 17
i got into enormous amounts of trouble
with the law
i did a lot of unethical things and i
was getting
myself in so much trouble and i had one
mentor
that my brother introduced me to his
name was alan brown he was a very
successful philanthropist
entrepreneur and he agreed to meet with
me for lunch one
day and he asked me like why are you
doing these things you seem like a nice
young kid and i said
i don't know i just want to make some
money and i just want to fit in
he goes but you seem like you're
intelligent why don't you just use your
brain's natural abilities i go listen
based on my education
and based on what the teachers have told
me i'm not going to do very well in life
and i left high school in grade 11
thinking that i'm not worthy enough i'm
not smart enough i'm not good enough
and this one man in one minute in
one meeting changed my life because he
asked me
what what goals do you have i said what
do you mean what goals do i have
i said i want to go out this weekend to
the bar i want to have some good food i
want to find a nice young lady maybe
hook up with and he says no no what are
your bigger goals
and i didn't have any so he actually
sent me home he said fill out these
pieces of paper and on the pieces of
paper it said like what age do you want
to retire by
like i was 19. this was may of 1980.
i wasn't even started yet i said but
just fill out
fill out these papers so i said i want
to retire by a time of 45
with 3 million dollars i want to have a
mercedes i want to have a house i want
to
travel the world i want to have a great
lifestyle and so i came back
on monday and he looked at it and he
asked me one question
and that question transformed my life
and he said are you interested in
achieving these goals
or are you committed and i stopped and i
and i looked at him he was standing up i
was sitting at my desk there
at his office and i asked him mr brown i
said what's the difference
and he said if you're interested you'll
do what's convenient
you'll come up with stories and excuses
and reasons why you can't and you'll use
your education as an excuse you'll use
your stories and excuse
you'll use the fact your father was a
cab driver and was a gambler and never
had any money
you'll use all of that as your reasons
why you can't he says
but if you're committed you will do
whatever it takes
you'll let go of your stories you'll let
go of your excuses you'll let go of all
the reasons you currently have that are
formulating your identity of yourself
and you learn how to let that go
and become who you are destined to
become so someone's listening right now
and they're thinking you know there's a
lot of things i want
you know i want to get out of this
relationship or i want the relationship
i want to have a better health i want to
have
more money whatever it may be and
they've been saying that for years
and they feel like they've been
consuming all the information they need
to have but they haven't been able to
take action
maybe because their why isn't powerful
enough what would you say should be
their first step
well the first step is to take one thing
i'm going to go back to
one thing yeah and say great let me move
one thing forward why because that just
changes the trajectory of
the same pattern repeating itself and as
soon as you
interrupt a pattern and then you
repeatedly interrupt the pattern it's
like taking a detour
and as soon as you take a detour one day
you're like okay that was that was okay
but you
intended your tendencies to want to go
back to what's comfortable but if you
take the detour two days
six days seven days we know from a
neuroscience perspective it takes about
66 days
to create a solid enough neural pattern
that it'll go from conscious
effort and thinking about it to a
non-conscious pattern that has the
beginnings
of automaticity happening without your
involvement you're just doing yeah and
so
for me what i do and for myself
is i uh whenever i want to change
something whether it's a habit whether
it's a thought or emotion or behavior
i say i'm going to work on this for 100
days not 30 days
not 21 days not 66 which is right around
there i say
100 days and then i focus
all of my just on that one thing for 100
days why can you give an example of
something you've done
sugar sugar sugar i'm a sugar
me too i'm a sugar like if it was an
alcoholic i'm a sugar a whole pizza
right
so you take one thing just one thing
that you know
maybe a little challenging 100 days 100
days just
100 days so let's say you want to drink
more water 100 days
a glass a day conscious effort to one a
day whatever you did before
you'll still do but one glass a day so
you know i started that with my
assistants i want to drink
you know like four of these a day you
know like you know 32 ounces whatever
the case is
and so every we got a mug and it's on my
desk
every time i walk in and then i have
some support from her saying hey
remember to drink your water
so i just do it so the first you know
two three weeks i feel like i'm gonna
drown myself with so much water
um but then it's like okay now i'm used
to it now i'm drinking as much water as
possible because the habit is there
and one of the rules that i love to
follow is the habit
is more important than the intensity at
first
so don't worry about the intensity right
develop the habit
so can you take one minute a day to
focus on how you
will achieve a goal just one minute a
day can you take
one minute a day to focus on your health
yeah can you take one day
to retrain your brain yeah can i take
one day
you know or one action a day right and
you start off with something you know
and reduce it down to just a minute or
two minutes or
one behavior if you can get that
behavior
to be a habit it's easy to stack right
of course
it's just like the foundation of a
building once you have the foundation
if you build it right you stack yeah and
so
every good discipline affects another
and every bad discipline
affects others let's say you have a fear
of public speaking is it really a fear
of public speaking that you have
or is it a fear of getting up on stage
and being embarrassed ashamed ridiculed
or
judged hmm let me take you to another
type of fear
being buried alive can you imagine for
just a moment
if there was an earthquake or there was
a natural disaster
and somehow you were buried alive
wouldn't that trigger this crazy amount
of fear of dying while you were buried
alive
now why am i taking you there i'm taking
you there because
fear is a subconscious trigger
whenever we feel threatened
and the threat could be a threat for our
very lives
and when that happens we move into one
of
four modalities and modality number one
is we try to fight this feeling
number two is we freeze because we're in
such
shock number three we may
faint because of the neurochemistry that
the fear
causes or we might run away
if we can run away now these
neurological
reactions are our brain's way of keeping
us safe which is the
highest need and desire of the brain
safety above all else so when
we are looking to achieve a goal that we
want to achieve
and it doesn't matter if it's you know
to start a business or grow your
business or leave a relationship
that you're not happy or a job that
you're miserable in
whenever we think about the actual
behavior that is required to achieve
that goal
once we get motivated in doing that
that's part one
of how our brain works but right after
that our brain has to analyze if there's
any real
or imagined danger associated with
taking that action step so if you are
going to
leave a relationship that you're not
happy in your brain
is going to activate the memory circuits
and
discover what's in there that may have
caused you
pain and suffering in the past
and when that happens whether it's a
relationship you want to leave
a job that you want to leave a goal you
want to achieve your brain is always
analyzing is there any danger here
and when there is real or imagined
danger
the amygdala part of the brain the
emotional response
center in the brain is going to fire off
an amazing amount of neurochemicals like
cortisol
epinephrine or norepinephrine and it's
that rush
of those neuro chemicals that causes
this
emotion energy in motion
we label as fear now
once you have that rush of
neurochemicals in your bloodstream
that actually gives you an enormous
amount
of energy but what most people
never have learned how to do is how to
take that energy
and channel it to action
versus the fighting it freezing or
running away
when you recognize a fear i want you to
do
this it's called inner size number one
it's called
take six calm the circuits when
fear neurochemicals are released in your
brain you've activated
the fear or stress response center in
the brain
when you just observe
the emotion called fear through being
quiet and breathing six times
in through your nose and out through
your mouth like this
you take a deep breath in for five
seconds
[Music]
you blow out like you're blowing out
through a straw
and if you do this five seconds in five
seconds out five
seconds in five seconds out with six to
ten breaths
you're going to deactivate the fear
response center
and that actually is going to reactivate
your thinking center in your brain
so that you can move on to inner size
number two inner size number one is take
six com the circuits
inner size number two is called ayah a
i a and that stands for awareness
intention action so here's how you do
this
after you do the first exercise then you
move to inner size number two
and then you ask yourself in a calm
relaxed
state what am i thinking
right now what am i feeling right now am
i
calm or am i tense am i breathing
deeply or shallow is my heartbeat
fast or slow and in this state of
calm awareness as you deactivate
the brain's fear or stress response
you can observe what you are feeling and
what you are
thinking and what you were doing and
then
you can ask yourself the next question
that is the i
what is my intention right now is my
intention to move forward or is my
intention to stay
in this fearful state and chances are
you say well i really want to move
forward and then you ask yourself what
is
one action step that i can take
to move forward towards my goal and
dream so this is how it works
after you do the inner size number one
to calm the circuits
and to deactivate the reactive state
that fear causes
and then you move into the second inner
size called aya
to move into the responsive state
awareness intention action now puts you
in control of being aware of the fear
being aware okay of what you've been
thinking
and then being at choice of what you
want to do
so when you combine these two inner
sizes you are now reconfiguring the
neural network in your brain
around the goal that you want to achieve
and instead of allowing
the real or imagined danger to control
you to stop you dead on your tracks
you take one action step in a calm
state and that rewires your brain
so that the same reaction doesn't hold
you back anymore
and that you are now able to use fear as
your
fuel for success i want to separate
like behaviors and emotions so usually
when people say they have
they're having a bad day sure certain
things may have gone wrong or something
that they
tried to do you know didn't work out
[Music]
all information and experiences are
processed at the non-conscious brain
first and then it gives rise to
something we call a feeling
so emotions are processed
non-consciously the
electrical and chemical reaction to that
is called a feeling
so when i'm not feeling
the way that i want to feel i don't
focus on the feeling i focus on the
cause the neuroelectrical
charge that's occurred in my brain and
in most cases
it's something that you're doing to
interpret
an event that's causing the
neuroelectrical signal
causing the feeling so in meditation for
example
why do you meditate well obviously it's
great for a whole
host of of health reasons whether it's
it's
less stress less you know lower blood
pressure
less cortisol release etc but the one
thing meditation does
more than anything else is it gives you
the ability to have
a pause of awareness so that you
sense what's happening at the
non-conscious level
right and what's happening outside of
you so when somebody behaves a certain
way
it's processed at the non-conscious
level gives rise to
your conscious mind for you to respond
and so when something happens i like to
be able to check in so that i don't
react and i have the ability to respond
and if you do that enough through
mindfulness being aware
just being aware of exactly what's going
on
then you have fewer and fewer of those
times
so you know something happened last week
i was
in a hotel room and i spilled some water
on a shirt that i needed
um for a wedding that we were going to
and my wife
was ah she was going off deep and i was
just calm
yeah and she was aren't you worried
about this will it help
right but no let's just figure out what
to do
the accident already happened when i was
a kid
i had a lot of my own challenges i
didn't have confidence in myself i
didn't believe in myself
i i had some big challenges you know
with the law
and getting into trouble in school and
getting into trouble outside of school
and i was really fortunate when i was 19
years old
i met a wonderful gentleman who was very
successful with his family he was very
successful
giving to charities he was very healthy
he was very
gentle and kind and he really wanted to
do good in the world
not just for himself but to make the
world a better place
and he started to teach me that
the reason i was getting into trouble
the reason i wasn't getting great
results was what i believed about myself
and he taught me the power of my beliefs
he taught me the power
of you know what i do every single day
matters he taught me the power
of the intelligence in the universe that
i could
utilize my brain like a radio
you know sends a signal out into the
universe he said you could send a signal
out using the power of your thoughts
he says but you're also capable of
receiving information
just like the great inventors whether it
was albert einstein whether it was
edison michelangelo
any of the great inventors they had
these ideas that came to them
and they were just normal human beings
but they took advantage
of the messages that they were getting
in their hearts and their intuition
and so he taught me some of the power of
the brain
and by using what i learned i
learned that i could achieve a lot more
than
i ever thought was possible when i was
younger i was really fortunate when i
was 19 years old
i met a wonderful gentleman who was very
successful with his family he was very
successful
giving to charities he was very healthy
he was very
gentle and kind and when he started to
share with me to teach me that
my entire reality was based on what
i believed was real and what i believed
was true about myself about what's
possible
and that i could change that that's when
my life started to change
and he said if you start to change the
way you think
and you start to learn every day for one
hour
to upgrade your knowledge and your
skills
and then you take action every day
on the things that are the most
important instead of all the different
things that you can do
it says if you focus on doing three to
five things
every day towards your goals he says in
one year
you'll be at a totally different
destination three years
big distance five ten years your life
won't be the same
and i was tired of living a mediocre to
less than mediocre life and so i said
listen
you seem to have a good plan
you're making millions of dollars you're
giving a lot of money to charity
you're happy you're healthy uh you've
got a great family
i want that he said if you want that
follow the blueprint don't try to figure
it out just
follow the blueprint and that was
another lesson that he shared with me is
that you don't have to
reinvent the wheel yes like if you want
to fly right now you don't have to
figure out how to fly
you know there's already a blueprint for
how to generate or create an airplane
yeah so if you want to be healthy
there's already a blueprint if you want
to make more money
there's already a blueprint if you want
to buy real estate or the stock market
or start a business and grow a business
there's people before us
that have already got the blueprint and
all you have to do is paint paint the
numbers inside
the box and then you can use your
creativity
so i just became a very good follower
for a long time
of things that worked and when you
follow things that work
it's like having the combination to a
safe
if someone gives you the combination to
a safe and they tell you turn this way a
little bit
this way a little bit turn this way a
little bit turn this way a little bit
then open it
you can have access to it but most
people
don't look for the combination and then
even when they get the combination
they try it in the wrong order the law
of goya
is simply get off your ass so if you if
you
if you if you think and you believe and
you emotionalize you visualize
and you create your plan for how am i
actually going to achieve this
so what do i need to do when am i going
to do it
how specifically how am i going to
tweak it measure it and iterate it so
that i'm consistently making progress
i learned the value of progress versus
perfection
none of my mentors ever had me focus on
perfection
they had me focus on progress to just
keep getting better
little incremental gains every day every
week every month every quarter
and even when you move backwards a
couple of steps what's the progress that
you made in what you learned
so i was taught that failure is an
opportunity to learn
and i was also taught to disassociate
me being a failure from failing for sure
right when you start talking about my
brain it's an organ it's like your heart
is an
organ you can speed up your heart you
can slow down your heart you can
you know speed up the brain waves in
your brain you can slow them down you
can
tune in you can tune out yeah we haven't
been given the user's manual for the
most
powerful tools we're aware of that's
right
and so the great news you know i know
you being an athlete and a successful
businessman
you have discipline you cannot i think
you can't achieve research he results
without some kind of discipline
and so we know that there's some
fundamental truths to achieving success
and every successful person will tell
you you know and jim rohn is i know you
you love generally so you either
pay the price of discipline or you pay
the price of regret discipline weighs
ounces regret weighs tons
that's good but the the thing is can you
teach discipline the answer is yes
how you have to have a willing
participant and
if the participants reason why
is big enough if they know i want to
achieve
x and the reason why the motive for
their action motivation the motive for
their
action is a reason beyond just
themselves
chances are they will do more yeah to
achieve that success than if it was just
left up to their own but there are some
people that are born
you know with incredible drive they just
have this insatiable drive
and they'll just i'll do whatever it
takes for the things that i
want and there's other people that want
things but they just don't have this
insatiable drive
and this is where you know i as much as
i hated school i love to use schools and
analogy
in the game of life whether it's health
wealth relationships career business
spirituality fun experiences you have to
decide what level of the game do i want
to play at
is it the great school level the
kindergarten level the high school level
the university level the pro level
because
each one of those levels requires a
totally different
mindset and totally different skill set
they're building blocks on each other
but if you are extremely
talented but you're not prepared to
practice and rehearse
and drill and fall and fail
forward to the next attempt you will
never make it as a pro
you will never make as a pro business
person you'll never make it as a pro
husband or wife or athlete or musician
you just
never will so just get used to that if
you're not prepared to pay the price
if you are prepared to pay the price and
you have the aptitude and the talent
now we're talking about there's some
real potential here
and what we don't know is you know
what's in your heart like what is the
fire
that stirs you that that you wake up
saying i will do this even when i don't
feel like it i will do whatever it takes
to
overcome my temptation for mediocracy my
temptation for excuses my temptation
for reasons and circumstances to hold me
back
i won't allow those to be in my way and
if you have
that within you you'll achieve whatever
you choose
right and so the question you asked
before is how do you develop that start
small
yeah start small so if you
don't have discipline show do you show
yourself that you can give yourself
one command and one follow-through so
you know what
right now i'm gonna get up i'm gonna do
two push-ups right now
not not like later now can you give
yourself a
simple command one sit-up right now i'm
gonna go get a glass of water
you start with something ridiculous i
learned many years ago reduce it
to the ridiculous so for reduce it to
the ridiculousness
i said can you do that great will you
because that's the difference right
there is that's the razor's edge the
people who
can will you will you yeah great when
now
now yeah right so if you develop that
skill
and specifically from a brain plasticity
a neuroplasticity perspective as soon as
you do that you give yourself a command
and you take the action you have just
created a neural pattern
you can give yourself a command and take
action now that maybe just be one time
well what if you did that every hour by
putting a little bell on your
computer and every hour like if you were
if my computer was open i'd have um
every hour it would say it's 12 o'clock
it's one o'clock and i take
sixty seconds just to be in control of
my mind
sixty-seven i don't care where i stop
what you're doing stop take six breaths
just get just get centered am i on track
am i off track am i doing something i
shouldn't be doing versus
a high impact activity that i need to be
doing every hour
i've trained myself to just reset i
didn't always do that so i just started
with
one a day right then two sure then
three then it was working so well i said
great let's do this every hour
part of the work that i love to do now
is is really help people understand
what is your story like what's the story
you're telling us
because we all have a story we have a
money story a relationship story a
health story
we have a story for everything and then
that story keeps recreating our lives
over and over and over again
and we have beliefs that support the
story we have habits that support the
story we have people that support the
store we have systems that support our
story
and so my question i always ask people
who would you be with a different story
i was born in tel aviv israel and moved
to montreal because my parents were
tired of raising their kids in a worn
torn
part of the world which was you know in
israel and the palestinian
areas i'm sure everybody felt that same
way that whole region
my parents moved to montreal from israel
and at the time i really had a hard time
learning the french and the english
language
and i developed some i guess self-esteem
issues that i wasn't smart enough or as
good as the other kids because i
couldn't communicate
when i was really young and then i got
into a lot of trouble
as a as a young teen from the age of 12
to 17 i got into a lot of trouble with
the law
mostly because i had low self-esteem
if you can believe that um i did at the
time
people have to make a decision what they
want to trade their life for
yes because every day we're trading our
life
for the people that we associate with
for
the business or job that we have you
know for what we eat for the health for
the enjoyment for the fun for the
experiences
and you have to ask yourself is my life
worth trading for that
if it's not today is a good day to stop
i know that right yeah but most people
don't think that they're trading their
life
you know for something they think that
you know there's tomorrow and there's
next week really
well i have you know evidence to prove
otherwise
that we have no idea you know when the
last breath will be
yeah so let's trade our life every day
as it's the most
important thing in the world and not
from an ego perspective
from uh from a humble grateful
perspective of wow i get
another day to live and to to enjoy be
grateful
to be grateful for that but then to
respect it
see respecting your life means you're
going to trade it
for things that you feel are worthy
of it most people you know ask
themselves the wrong question
they ask themselves you know am i worthy
of the goal and the dream that i have
and they should be asking themselves is
that goal that dream that i have
worthy of my life
change the question and if you say yeah
i'll trade my life for that good then go
and do that
talk to me about set points that was
something really interesting
in what you talk about around the
stories and things that we carry that i
found really interesting
sure so maxwell maltz wrote a great book
many many years ago in the probably the
70s
called psycho cybernetics right and
maxwell maltz was a
surgeon who performed surgery on people
and what he noticed is
even after plastic surgery that he
performed on people
some people didn't see any change in
their faces and it was
visible to everybody else but not to
them because they had a map
of what they thought they look like yes
okay so we all
have a map of reality we have a map of
what we think we look like and any
deviation
on the physical level to that map to
that
visual representation we have in our
brains that doesn't match the map
your brain deletes or distorts it so
when we were working with real estate
agents or when i worked with business
owners
in addition to upgrading knowledge and
skills
if you think about how let's say income
we have
set points for how much income we earn
so whether it's 10 000 a year or 20 or
50 or 100 or a million it doesn't matter
we get this set point and then we behave
the way we need to behave and we feel
what we need to feel to earn that income
and over a period of time it becomes
part of the brain's default mode
network so we develop set points for
everything and so if the set points in
the brain
and there's a psycho-cybernetic
mechanism in the brain a control and
response mechanism
in the brain and it's our brain
why not learn how to reset the set point
and so now we're looking at what
technologies are available to help help
reset that
what evidence-based methods are there to
set that
or to reset that and so when we take
let's say visualization
right and you start to see yourself even
if the picture is not
clear in your mind of achieving the next
level of your success whether it's
releasing weight and keeping it off
getting into a relationship that you
love and are happy and whether it's to
make
two or three or five times more money
and live a certain type of lifestyle
that allows you to do the things
that freedom with having money allows
you to do
if you start in your mind first and you
impress
that through conscious efforts into the
subconscious mind
it then causes thoughts and emotions and
behaviors
so i like to work from the outside in
and from the inside out
so use both i want every advantage
is your financial governor holding you
back from doubling or tripling your
income
in the next six to 12 months now you may
be asking
john what in the world is a financial
governor and
i'll explain it this way many years ago
when the car companies were building
engines that were faster and stronger
and more resilient
cars could go 200 250 miles an hour some
maybe even to 300 miles an hour
but because of laws in europe and in the
united states
these governors were put on the engine
so that the car
even though it can go faster and perform
even better
it was limited to about 155 miles per
hour
so here we are we have these cars that
can go extremely fast
but for obvious reasons to conserve on
gas
to be able to have more safety on the
roads and
to keep us generally all driving around
the same speed limit
we created these governors to put on
engines
in order to limit the speed at which the
car can go at
well what does that have to do with you
earning more money
you accumulating more wealth and the
answer is
everything if you understand
that you have a conscious brain that
wants to set
goals but you have a subconscious mind
that is going to limit your thoughts
emotions feelings
and behaviors to what you are
governed by which is your subconscious
mind
then here's one of the things that we
have discovered
people who make thirty thousand dollars
a year or fifty or a hundred or five
hundred thousand dollars a year or a
million dollars a year or more
their financial governor is set at a
totally different
setting than somebody who's earning less
so why does this make a difference well
it makes a difference because there's a
part of your brain
that chooses the goal that you want to
achieve
and there's another part of your brain
that's responsible for everything else
your thoughts emotions feelings and
behaviors
and so if you don't have coherence
between
these two parts of your brain if you
don't know how to remove the governor
and reset it chances are you're going to
have goals and dreams
financial ones and even lifestyle ones
that you're not going to achieve not
because
you're not capable of doing it it's just
because
you are wired set conditioned programmed
whatever you want to call it
to earn the income you're earning right
now and maybe a little bit more
each day each week each month versus
doubling or triple or quintupling your
income
now let me give you a different visual
for this that'll hopefully
cement what i mean let's say you're
in a room that has a thermostat in there
and the thermostat is set to a nice and
comfortable
70 degrees and you feel nice at that
temperature
what happens if you open up a window and
let's say it's winter
and cold air comes in well what happens
is the mechanism in the thermostat
that picks up what the temperature is in
the room picks up a deviation that cold
air has come in the room and what does
it do it sends a signal through the
electrical system
for the heater to go on so that the room
gets back to 70 degrees that's called a
cybernetic mechanism a control and
respond mechanism
that occurs in machines that we create
them in
or in animals like us so whether it's
hot air coming into a room
or cold air coming into a room any
deviation from the set program
activates the air conditioning or the
heat until
the program and the room are one and the
same
that is a cybernetic mechanism as i
mentioned and here's what happens
in us humans if you're used to earning
thirty thousand or fifty thousand
seventy five a hundred or two hundred or
more
or you are used to a certain lifestyle
any deviation up or down from
that setting that comfort zone that
programming
kicks in your nervous system so that you
either turn up the jets and earn more
based on what you're used to
or if you do really well for a week a
month a quarter
you actually back off and sabotage your
success
until you meet the setting that you have
in your mind that is how a governor
works in a car that's how a governor
works in your brain
so if you want to double or triple
your income in the next six months 12
months two years
doesn't it make sense that you should
reset your financial governor the
expectation point the programming the
conditioning
well of course it does what i've seen
in my years of training whether it's
sales people or
entrepreneurs or individuals to make
more money
is the ones that think that they could
do it just by
gaining more knowledge miss the point
because it's a part of our brain that
gains more knowledge but doesn't change
behavior
what you have to do is reprogram your
financial
set point your conditioning the
expectation point
and when you do that and you create this
coherence between your goal and your
dream and your
subconscious programming that is when
your behavior starts to change
that is when fears dissipate that is
when you stop procrastinating that is
when you take inspired action
and you don't sabotage the success that
you are achieving
so in order to achieve your goals and
dreams you have to reset
your governor reset your financial
thermostat
self-talk is so critical and so i'm
consistently paying attention
to how am i speaking to myself am i
speaking to myself in a kind
motivating empathetic compassionate way
or am i consistently self-deprecating
and putting myself down
i used to think a lot like when i was
younger i'm not good enough i'm not
smart enough i'm not worthy
um those thoughts uh and you know lots
of fear fear of being embarrassed
fear of failure fear of being ashamed
and i still have
the thoughts every once especially when
i'm setting new goals
those come up holy mackerel they come up
so freaking fast
are you smart enough to achieve that are
you good enough to achieve that even
when i got into
really diving deep into the brain
science and even my new book
i had i was petrified to release my book
it took me two years to write it
because now i'm entering another whole
domain of neuroscience and
neuropsychology with world-renowned
experts that i've worked with for years
but now here i am putting myself out
there with hey this is
neuroscientifically correct so i had to
make sure that it was
but there's a lot of fear but i
understand what the emotion of
fear is it's a subconscious trigger that
causes this feeling that i don't like
and it's a ghost signal for me not a
stop signal for me
if you have a big enough reason
why you want to achieve something you'll
do whatever it takes
yeah but if your reason isn't big enough
your excuses will be so it's a kind of
balance
it's it's always a balance yeah and
we're always looking to be in harmony
right we want harmony just like an
orchestra yes
and you want harmony between the
different areas of your life so that it
flows
and sometimes there's areas that are
really great
areas that are not and other times it's
a little calmer
and the more you can be in that nice
gentle flow
the more your life works and then i i
find that the happier people are
in the past i used to teach and also do
uh visualize my goals
whether it's my body health
relationships money charity whatever i
used to visualize the outcome
and some of the latest research now
shows um
in addition to visualizing the outcome
visualize the obstacles
and in the past when we talk about this
law of attraction no don't visualize the
ops because you attract them to no no
your brain's way smarter than that
so if you have whether it's a belief
that's in your way
um a story that's holding you back a
circumstance
references it you know something that's
holding you back
from achieving x so take a look at
whatever it is that you already know is
holding you back i don't believe i'm
worthy i don't believe i'm smart enough
don't mean that i'm good enough don't
believe me if i'm skilled if i'm
too young too old i'm i'm to this or to
that or not enough of this not enough
that
so address that and say okay here is an
obstacle
i'm going to visualize that obstacle
being real and i'm going to visualize
just moving it aside and me moving
towards my goal
the very act of acknowledging that
releases the neural tension around if
you do that over and over and over again
what your brain starts to see is yes
there was a struggle
and so it's worthy of me creating this
neural pattern around this new effort
right because most of what we're doing
is you know we're being we're on
autopilot
we're just eeking through the day you
know on autopilot
and so the brain loves anything that
makes it curious the brain likes
anything
novel the brain likes a challenge so
earlier you're asking me about you know
one of the brain training companies
other than ours
he said does it work i said yeah it's a
workout for your brain
and if you can strengthen the neural
patterns of you seeing yourself
with an obstacle and overcoming it what
do you think that does to your self
confidence and certainty builds it up
builds it up so if you'd if you actually
do the work and develop those patterns
in your brain
as you're doing the stuff you need to do
in the physical world you just
strengthen those neural patterns
that's what becomes your habits i was
taught the law of attraction you know i
was 23 24 years old
um also at a real estate conference they
were talking about this
law of attraction thing that there's
this energy everything's made up of
energy i am energy you are energy
and my thoughts you know create this
resonance between what i attract and
what i don't
i'm like oh god i like that you know
like i want to attract more of the good
stuff right
um and so i i i bought in like i bought
into stuff that just made sense to me
but then i was a voracious
student i wanted to understand how
like explain to me how it works like if
somebody tells me visualize
i go why like how does it work like
you asked me to visualize like why does
it work like why should i invest my time
on that versus something else
if you're asking me to use affirmations
like how specifically
why how does it work if you're asking me
to emotionalize well
what's happening in me that tell me i
need to create these false
senses of feelings i want to know why it
works
think about the era that our parents
lived
okay great depression yeah right
um very very hard to make money very
very hard to find resources very very
hard to to do anything unless you're a
professional
so our parents said to most of us if you
don't become a professional
uh you're gonna struggle you're going to
struggle and suffer and
even the professionals said okay so
become a professional and here's your
ceiling
of what you have so we became
conditioned to be worried of scarcity
in a world that has no scarcity we
became conditioned to having certain
beliefs about what's possible or not
possible
so even now you know as we as we we were
sitting here and we've got this you know
amazing election time crazy you know the
things i've been thinking about is
you know there are some people that
believe that if donald trump wins
they're going to make a fortune and
there's other people who think they're
going to lose everything
and i have a friend of mine who has got
about 70 million in the bank that
believes that if hillary gets into
office he's going to lose millions
it's going to be really tough and what
really is
you know going on in people's heads it's
it's all of their references
their beliefs and their perceptions that
are locked away
in the implicit part of their brain that
is driving
those thoughts and even the behaviors
they may not be aware of it they're not
even aware of it
yeah they can be but there may not be
and so
what we really have to go back to to
focus on
is it really makes no difference who
becomes
president or who doesn't if you have the
belief that regardless of what happens
in your
external world you can navigate towards
the success that you want right
that's a belief and beliefs are the lens
by which we actually see the world and
by which we
behave and so if you want to change your
results don't focus on changing your
behaviors change your focus on the
beliefs that drive your behaviors
every human being has a relationship
with money and money is something that
um envelops people's brains about what
they buy what they don't buy
whether they buy you know a business
class or first class
or regular economy seats whether they're
always looking for the cheapest
or the most expensive the nicest uh or
uh
average how much they will tip how much
they want we all have
a money story that we've developed
mostly from our parents and
the people that we live near and we
developed this relationship around
money and our beliefs around money
you know are we good enough to earn that
amount
are we worthy enough to earn that amount
um
is it is it worth it or not and so
one of the things that mary morrissey
says that we should do she says for
seven days
write down the thoughts you have about
money and notice when you're thinking
um and notice what you are thinking and
notice that the money story
you're telling yourself is it positive
negative is it abundance thinking or
limited thinking is it scarcity thinking
or is it what fill in the blank
and so once you know your money story
and this is also
something that one of our um um
psychiatrists who works with us dr david
kruger says
once you know the story the money story
that's when you can start to be aware of
it and go wow
where did i get these limiting beliefs
about money about my
value where do i get these limiting
beliefs of what i can afford what i
can't where i get these limiting beliefs
around how i behave
with money let's say you have a car
which i imagine
most people who are watching have a car
imagine you're driving your car
and a light comes on the dash
it's like oh i wonder what that light is
and you look a little bit closer
and it says there's a little you're low
on oil
uh in the engine okay so you're aware of
that
and the light stays on and then two
seconds later another light comes on
hey what's going on and it says that the
rear tire is
low on air ah what the hell is going
on and so you keep driving you say at
the next
gas station i'm going to stop and i'll
fill up the air and um
i'll put some oil in the um in the
engine
so that i top everything up now why am i
using that example
when we have an emotion
all emotions everybody pay close
attention
you have emotions you are not
your emotions emotions are different
than
feelings emotions happen
as a autumn as an automatic
subconscious trigger when your brain is
evaluating something you want
to do or something that you are doing
against the memory that's
in there that's causing this old emotion
of how you felt or what you did or what
you were thinking or what you were
experiencing
at the time that the memory was created
so all emotions are processed at the
subconscious level
and whatever pattern is associated with
that behavior that you're doing right
now or the
incoming stimuli from the outside world
is going to trigger
this emotion which then sends a
neurochemical release
that you feel as guilt and has the
thought patterns of guilt
or the emotions of being embarrassed
the feeling is the conscious awareness
of the cocktail of neurochemicals that
have been released
but the emotion is subconscious so
is it possible to recalibrate
a neurological pattern in the brain
is it possible if a pattern is nothing
more than neurons that have been
coalesced or connected can you
interrupt a pattern from the past
is it possible to interrupt a pattern
from the past
so answer that question is it possible
to interrupt a pattern from the past of
course it's
possible any pattern that exists in the
brain is nothing more
than a group of neurons brain cells that
in many cases have
ten thousand connections okay at the end
of each neuron
that formulate this connectedness
between the neurons
so you can interrupt a pattern just like
you can
interrupt and create a new habit you can
interrupt an emotional pattern a
behavioral pattern
a feeling pattern and you can interrupt
it using a variety of
methodologies you can take a pattern
and you can visualize it getting smaller
you can
accentuate it with colors with uh
animal uh images with visualization with
meditation with
mindfulness with affirmation with
subliminal programming
you can interrupt patterns and even more
important than that based on the latest
research on neuroplasticity
you can create a new pattern
and that becomes the new default pattern
the parts of the brain that register
and experience versus the part of the
brain that can
imagine an experience are not different
so if i imagine doing a bicep curl
in my mind i see my arm moving and i'm
doing a bicep curl
in my mind i'm accessing the occipital
lobe
part of my brain it is no different than
me going to the gym and doing a bicep
curl so
when you do both you solidify the
experience
even more now i want to just talk about
what you just said about your partner
who brings in meditation when most
people
are asked to do something that they're
fearful of
the sympathetic nervous system in the
brain kicks in
in nanoseconds not in minutes in
nanoseconds that's the fight
or flight response system in the brain
so they want to run away or they freeze
and they can't do
anything but if you take that same
experience that you want them to do
and you have them do it in their mind
first
in a calm state so first if you have
them visualize
doing that and they feel nervous but you
just have to do
one little thing six breaths why
six breaths we know from the research
now
that if you imagine in your mind doing
something that you're
fearful of and you allow
the parasympathetic nervous system to
rule
that means that you're going to be
shallow breathing you're going to raise
your blood pressure
you're going to activate your sweat
glands and you're going to activate all
of the fight or
fear response mechanism the fight or
flight response mechanisms
and that is a very tense situation to be
in
what if you could take somebody and have
them imagine that exact same thing but
before they take the action
they see themselves they just take 60
breaths one
see yourself doing it two three
four five six what happens is because
you're breathing deeply in and
out your parasympathetic nervous system
okay kicks in why because that is the
relaxed
response mechanism in the brain so if
you
consciously activate your relaxation
response mechanism
with something that would normally be
stressful for you
you actually deactivate the fear center
in the brain the amygdala
and you actually open up your thinking
center of your brain the genius part of
your brain
that can actually override the fear
center of the brain
it's a small little mechanism that you
can just learn how to do
so i say you do both not
one or learn both goes back to
upgrade your knowledge and skills of
saying why am i afraid which
system of mine you know is operating
right now so think about this
when we walk into a room we could flip
the switch and turn on the light because
we want more light
well why not flip your own genius switch
why not
flip off the switch of fear and anxiety
and stress
and flip on the switch of calmness
certainty
and creativity there it's your switch
we just haven't been taught how to turn
one switch off and turn one switch on
highly successful people whether they're
taught it like we teach it or they just
know how to do it
automatically they do it no matter
what has happened to us in the past yes
whether it's a traumatic event a failure
somebody who's hurt us a mistake that
we've made
we have to understand that the way that
our brain
works is it it does as much as possible
to move
away from anything that could
potentially
hurt us so the first thing that your
brain does is keep you alive
yes but the second thing that it does is
it keeps you
away from hurting yourself
whether it's real or imagined your brain
will move away first
protection mechanism first so if you've
had
an experience from the past where you've
made a mistake or you've disappointed
yourself
you've disappointed other people your
parents
your parents your teachers your brothers
your sisters your coworkers
your brain is always looking for
associations and similarities
in what you want to do that might lead
to the same disappointment
or the same pain that you've had before
and as soon as it senses any type of
correlation
it lights up the part of the brain that
remembers the past
and brings all of your past into the
present moment so you
feel it and projects the possible
negative consequences into the future
as soon as that happens your motor
cortex shuts off the part of your brain
that takes action in the motivational
centers of your brain
it just shuts off and what it does it
either
it either fights it it freezes so that
you are paralyzed
or it makes you run away the other way
yeah so that's
one part of the brain that works but if
you understand that when that happens
you have an emotion and it might be an
emotion of fear
fear of disappointment fear of success
fear of failure fear of abandonment fear
of rejection there's 50
or more fears that we have as human
beings that
we're always aware of in the environment
and if you realize that those fears
are possible but they're not certain
what we have to teach ourselves is to be
aware that those are possible
not certain but then to flip the switch
to the left
prefrontal cortex part of the brain
which is really the
brain that comes up with solutions it's
the brain that comes
up with you know directions instructions
strategies and tactics on how to make it
happen
instead of all the things that could go
wrong
so we have different parts of the brain
that are responsible for different
functions
most people don't know that they can
switch from this part of the brain to
that part of the brain they could lower
the amygdala part of the brain that's
responsible for fear and the
emotional response of fear in the brain
that sends you know epinephrine or
cortisol
neurotransmitters in the brain that we
feel in our body
and then we feel these neurotransmitters
in our body then we
think about what we're feeling and then
we feel more about what we think about
and if that's what we only focus on yes
then it keeps perpetuating the exact
same cycle
but we have that's why people are
repeating
same mechanism right yeah there's
there's
a term in the neuroscience field
in the brain research field called
repetition compulsion
so we have a compulsion
to repeat things over and over and over
again whether they're good or bad
is irrelevant so we will just keep
repeating stuff
even when we do things that don't give
us the result that we want
we become addicted to that result in
that emotional
state in our brain and in our bodies
yeah and so if we repeat that over and
over and over again
we become addicted to that emotional
state
and then we just repeat it becomes
because it becomes automatic
well fear is an emotion emotions are all
triggered at the subconscious level they
release neurochemicals that causes a
feeling
we are consciously aware of feelings
that are triggered at the subconscious
level the feeling is the
end point of the human experience in the
physical body
and so when you have something in your
brain that
that a neural network says well uh what
if this book comes out and you failed
what if it's not good enough what is
scientifically not correct what if what
if what if my brain is going to process
that the same way as your brain and
everybody else because
that's everybody's brain is the same the
mechanism of how the brain works
it's einstein's brain hitler's brain
genghis khan's brain
tom biliu's brain john acetate all the
same functionality
so if you understand the mechanics of
what's supposed to happen
then you say okay great when i feel this
then what am i going to do
so i like to use an analogy of a car
you're driving a car
and you're talking to a friend of yours
and a light pops up on the dash
you don't take a hammer and hit a light
it's a signal something's happening
in the in the in the in the engine in
the trunk in the in the tires
something's happening
emotions and feelings aren't uh positive
or
negative they're empowering or
disempowering to varying degrees if you
don't understand them
so what does your morning routine look
like now what what's
you know so today was a little bit
different except for one thing because i
drove from san diego to la to be with
you
but i wake up i pee i do my meditation
20 to 30 minutes every morning i don't
care where i am in the world during that
time
i i do a variety of different
meditations so there's meditations that
i can do
where i'm just observing my thoughts now
a lot of people think well
i thought you're not supposed to have
thoughts when you meditate says whom
there's hundreds of different ways to
practice
awareness see meditation is the art of
awareness
awareness internally awareness
externally but also the
various millions of layers that exist
in the physical and the non-physical
world so
this morning i did a meditation with
some ocean
sounds and so it was um about five
o'clock i woke up this morning sat in my
little sofa you know my feet propped up
and did a
20-so minute meditation in the dark with
the ocean
just listening to the ocean just paying
attention going into a trance-like state
where after two or three minutes like i
disappeared like my body
was part of air and space so today was i
was using sound
to get into that trance-like state other
days i'll do
a mantra whether it's you know a lot of
people know transcendental meditation so
it's the
mantra so you just take a deep breath in
and then as you exhale
[Laughter]
and the question is why would you do
that and the answer is anytime you can
give your brain
a rhythm it will entrain to that rhythm
that's
one anytime you could pay attention to
your breath
inhale and exhale you turn off the
parasympathetic nervous system
um you could you turn on the
parasympathetic nervous system which is
your rest and relaxation
and your calm state of flow versus your
sympathetic nervous system which is the
stress response system of adrenaline
norepinephrine cortisol etc so when you
get the serotonin oxytocin and dopamine
going
and you're in that state of calmness uh
you're able to enter deeper
levels of consciousness and awareness so
you're able to observe a thought
you're able to hear your heartbeat
you're able to
sense different things that are giving
are being risen in your body through
thoughts that you're having so you can
actually start to see
when i have this thought here's the
sensation in my body
and you start to get so attuned to
what's happening what stimuli is
happening within you that's producing
these sensations
that cause you to either take action or
not retreat or move forward
you can start to get a feel for how the
mechanics work
so so do that sometimes i'll put on some
of the tibetan monks and chant with them
uh so i use sound no sound i use
breathing i use open eye
close die five minutes ten minutes 30
minutes so i practice
the art of being in control of my breath
not breathing just being one with the
entire universe and feeling this
other than normal state of consciousness
that we're used to
it's not sleep and it's not you know
conscious awareness you're in an
altered state of awareness and you can
you can
enter deeper and deeper and deeper
layers
of energy which everything is made up
anyway everything's connected we have
this obviously our physical body
but the space between you and i right
now there's just
vibrating packets of energy right and so
you're able to access
different layers of all of the
intelligence and information
that already exists in the universe
versus the memories that we have in our
brains
and that's magical when i was um
five six seven years old i moved from
israel to
montreal i spoke hebrew but not english
or french
and for two and a half years i felt dumb
i felt like i wasn't smart enough and i
wasn't good enough and i was
made fun of as a kid that led to me
being involved in street gangs from the
age of 12
to 16 in montreal in montreal wow
we traffic drugs from florida we did
break-in entries we
we had a little streak gang about 12 of
us that just got into a lot of trouble
my path was either jail or the morgue
one of the two and uh there's a lot of
successful people that have that kind of
a story for some strange reason
um and at 19 i met a mentor his name was
alan brown he was a real estate
developer
still in montreal uh no this was in i
moved from montreal after
years of turbulence i finally broke free
and moved from montreal to toronto which
is about
350 miles in canada yeah and um
may 1980 i took uh my real estate course
june 20th 1980 became licensed as a real
estate agent and the reason i did i met
a man the weekend before
that my brother introduced me to who was
interpersonal
development yeah and he was into you
know zig ziglar and dennis waitley and
brian tracy's you know 35 years ago
and he introduced me to this world of of
you know the mind introducing me the
world of changing my beliefs changing my
habits changing my perceptions
of first who are you and he really
helped me see that
you know the spiritual greatness within
everybody the intelligence that's within
everybody he had me start with
getting in touch with that and it was
very philosophical
and didn't have the evidence that we
have today
on affirmations visualization meditation
mindfulness subliminal programming uh
habit creation
in all of the different methodologies
that we've all heard about whether it
was the astronauts that went to the moon
initially that trained their brains
or the musicians that have or the
athletes that do
the science now is just so phenomenal on
what is actually happening and so
as i was building my own companies i
built my companies by
training my employees not on the skills
that they needed
but on how spectacular they were as
human beings
and the greatness was within them and if
they trained their brain
to have the belief that it is they may
not have the skill or the know-how but
if you have the belief that i can
i will i must you can build a habit you
can build the habit you can
if you think about this i don't care if
you if we asked any question on health
wealth relationships career business
spirituality we wanted to
find the answer to something yeah we
could google it and within minutes have
everything we want to know tutorials
videos audios how to step by step
blueprint
color coordinate whatever you want so
our problem isn't
how to all the how to exists how to
build a business exists
how to be a great lover exists you know
it all exists how to get in shape
right so i wanted to focus on you know
how do i help more people take more of
the action they know they should be and
want to
we have this phenomenal brain right it's
it's it's
genius abilities we can't figure out how
to
replicate it anywhere with billions of
dollars
but we are getting some of the user's
manual now so when you feel
fear what should you do i teach the
first two inner sizes that i teach
every one of our students number one is
called take six calm the circuits
so if you have this unpleasant anxious
fearful emotion energy in motion
right and it's unpleasant and the breaks
have gone on
if you just take six deep breaths in
through your nose
out through your mouth like you're
breathing through a straw you will
deactivate the stress response center
which means blood is going to go back to
the left prefrontal cortex the einstein
part of the brain can actually think
through this problem
because what happens when the stress
response center is activated blood goes
away from that into the fear response so
you have epinephrine cortisol adrenaline
to be able to get you out of the
situation it's part of our
instinctual brain part of the reptilian
brain the first part of the brain that
was developed was that
then the mammalian brain the limbic
system then the neocortex the thinking
brain
so when our brain has this signal of oh
my god you might get hurt you might lose
this you might get in trouble you might
be embarrassed or shamed ridiculed
judged et cetera that part of the brain
is going to get activated so if you take
six deep breaths
first calm down calm the circuits first
then do inner size number two is called
ayah aia
the first day is for awareness what am i
thinking right now what am i feeling
right now what am i sensing right now
what is my behavior right now to you
thoughts feelings sensations awareness
of behavior
what's my intention right now that's the
i well my intention is to move forward i
want to do this
great what's one very small
action step that you can take now the
reason
you want to take one small action step
is
one small action step your brain can
handle
if it's one small step towards it the
threat
response goes away but if you focus on
the
end game right away you're gonna get
that rush
and that instant trigger of the fear
response stress response
so the first thing you want to do is
learn how to manage your mindset
and what you focus on learn how to
manage your emotions because they drive
your behavior
more than anything else because we move
away from pain and we move towards
pleasure but we move away from pain
a thousand times faster and pain wires
in the brain faster for survival
mechanisms
so purely from a neuroscience
perspective just understanding self
once you understand okay this feeling is
normal
okay what should i do take six con the
circuits
ayah and now you can start being
progressive and make progress towards
what you want
there's something in the weight loss
industry field called the fat
set point and every brain has a fat set
point
and it basically states that you have a
set point just like a thermostat
that's programmed in a room to have a
set point
we have fat set points we have financial
set points we have relationship
set points we have these set points that
we become accustomed to achieving
and then all of the supporting evidence
the stories the themes the plot lines
the perceptions and behaviors all must
match the set point
and so you can ask yourself two
questions number one is how did that set
point get there
and then how do i change it right so how
it got there is through all of your
conditioning
through what you've read what you've
done what you've experienced what you've
been told what you've seen
all of that has created your financial
set point
based on your story and so the first
thing to recognize
is the set point can be changed and the
question is how
right and that's the million dollar
question so number one
what drives behavior more than anything
else
it's not skill it's not knowledge skill
and knowledge is potential power but
what
does drive behavior more anything else
is beliefs
and so if there is a belief
in the brain that says yes you know i
think i'm capable of achieving
double my income would just use double
my income but there's another
belief that opposes that that causes
what we
what we know is as neural dissonance
so it creates a chaotic vibration in the
brain between the conscious and
non-conscious mind
so the key is to get alignment between
the new goal which is a
conscious pattern of thought that you
can choose in an instant
and the non-conscious part of the brain
around that goal
so how do you develop a belief right so
it's a pattern so
if i gave you a sentence and
you said that sentence one time you're
probably great it'd be a sentence like
when i was like hearing a line in a song
one time but if you heard a line in a
song
repeatedly 20 30 40 50 times
and you had other associations with that
to reinforce that pattern then you would
start to develop a non-conscious pattern
through that so we know that using let's
say visualization you're actually
bypassing the conscious mind and you're
accessing
the visual cortex of the brain it's a
non-conscious process the visual
processor
and so if we take words and we affirm
them and we
feel them and we visualize and repeat
them 100
200 500 000 times now we start to create
a pattern at the non-conscious level
that basically reinforces the conscious
desire
a lot of people ask me about money all
the time it's one of the things we teach
people how to do is grow their
businesses and how to make
more money and they say well you know i
want to make more money
i said well in order to make more money
first you have to believe
that you can right then you have to
believe you deserve it
then you have to make sure that you have
something that you can earn money with
so it's either going to be your ideas
you want to you can sell your ideas
yeah like a trainer you can sell your
time
you can sell your product you can sell
your services
which means that you have to have some
skill
or you have to have somebody else who
could do it for you you have to
see your skill right well you have to
either see your skill or
determine what skills are needed okay
and if you don't have
it get somebody else who has it to help
you
and so when when somebody tells me i
want to make more money i say them
let's say we have a pen i don't have a
pen here but if we had a pen
yes and we wanted to make money we could
go
and find somebody who wants to buy this
pen
right now and how much is somebody
willing to pay for the pen
well if the pen is worth a dollar
maybe you can get a dollar for it but
what about finding somebody
who needs it because they have to sign a
contract that's due in 10 minutes
that person might pay a hundred dollars
for that pin
yeah so our job is to take
you know our skills our knowledge our
products our services
our abilities and to be able to present
it to people who need it
and want it in exchange for
money i think feeling and knowing that
you've
used your life in a way that makes
yourself
proud that you're proud of you you felt
like
what a journey and i left it all out on
the field
and i just left it all in the field
that's my own greatness
you know knowing that i used my life in
a way that i left it all out on the
field that the the bruises the bangs
you know the trials the tribulations the
highs the lows that
you used it as soon as you blame
shame or justify you are disempowering
yourself
instead of being responsible
for your emotions your feelings your
attitude
and your actions when you take
responsibility
then you are not at the mercy of the
outside world and what
happens in the outside world you
learn how to upgrade your emotional
ability so whether you are happy or
sad or disgusted or frustrated or angry
or fearful you know how to navigate the
emotions that causes either the
motivational center in your brain to
light up or the fear center in your
brain to light up
thereby causing you to stop and
procrastinate and not take action
in many cases with adults we have to
unlearn
what we learned in the past what we
learned in the past and
one of my friends wrote a really good
book what got you here
won't get you there so
if yeah if you want to
achieve another result that you've never
achieved before who is he
um marshall goldsmith okay i see
yeah and um wonderful wonderful man
and so if we want to achieve another
result that we've never achieved before
then we have to become somebody
different
we have to upgrade our skills we have to
upgrade our behaviors we have to
um master our emotions better because
we're going to meet resistance
yes and we don't like change the human
brain and body doesn't like
change i've said for 30 years now the
only human being that likes change
is a baby with a wet diaper
yeah as the only human being that likes
change everybody else likes
i like everything just the way it is
yeah and so
and as we get older it becomes harder
and harder to change because the
patterns in the brain are so strong
if you think about an oak tree yes and
if you looked
underneath the ground to the root system
it's connected to all the other oak
trees maybe for
miles around all interconnected it's
hard to change
it's hard to change it because you can
pull the oak tree but you still have all
the roots that are connected
and if you had a little baby tree that's
maybe been there for one year
it's much easier to go in yeah and pull
the tree out and
take the root system out and so as we
get older
we become more and more conditioned to
be
more and more the same
so it's not that change isn't possible
it's most people aren't willing to
commit
to switching from what's comfortable
to what's not long enough
for the new to be comfortable while
you're
in the you know in the uh what am i
thinking feeling
it's a chance to be aware and the
biggest gift we have as human beings
is our awareness because awareness is
what gives you
choice and choice is what gives you
freedom most people are living their
lives in a reactive state
automatic reactive state because of
these set points that we talked
started talking about so we're in this
repetitive cycle
over and over and over and over we react
to the same things we behave the same
way we eat the same foods we dress the
same way
just to maintain that homeostasis and
comfort zones and we've never been
taught like when
were we taught as kids like here are
your six core emotions
here's the way you deactivate you know
your stress center or fear so here's how
you activate your imagination center
here's how you have more focus here's
how you develop a new belief here's how
you develop a new habit here's how you
release one
we haven't been taught that we've been
told they're important things
but we haven't been given the tools and
then we haven't practiced the tools
enough to be able to make them part of
our unconscious competence brain
well the key factors to becoming a loser
let's imagine that
together we build the training to help
people become a loser
yeah repeatedly thinking
feeling and doing the wrong things
every day okay great things okay
do you have another one hanging around
with the wrong people your environment
is it working
your environment shapes who you are okay
very very much when i was getting into
trouble as a young man
the people that i was hanging around
with were also getting into trouble
when i was a little boy i remember my
father
he used to tell me says show me who your
friends are and i'll tell you who you
are
yeah and so you're going to be
the sum of the people that you invest
the most amount of time with
whether it's at home your friends your
family or your business
people so if you tend to be around
winners
you'll start to buy by sheer
environmental factors listen and learn
how they think you'll be able to observe
what they do
you'll learn the skills that they've
acquired
and if you hang around with losers
you'll see
patterns everything in life is about a
pattern
and so people who are unsuccessful and
losers
which i don't even like to use the the
the term
loser although there are some not a lot
um
they have got habitual patterns of
destruction
self-sabotaging thoughts and
self-sabotaging behaviors
and people who are successful i don't
mean just financially
people who are successful in their
health their relationships
charitable contributions they have
consistent
successful patterns that are
constructive
towards being successful after i you
know got to real estate and i traveled
the world
i um i ended up buying the franchising
rights for re max for the state of
indiana
and i was 26 years old and i bought the
franchising rights for india and i moved
to indiana
and i remember being interviewed for the
indianapolis business journal and the
guy said what are your goals here in
indiana 26 years old i was wearing you
know
i remember a brown pinstripe suit
i had glasses on even though i didn't
need glass i just wanted to look older
and i said we'll do a billion dollars in
sales in indiana
and the gentleman said to me says are
you certain of that i said well that's
my goal
he says well their two largest companies
have been here for 100 years
don't do a hundred million dollars a
hundred
or a billion dollars combined and my
cocky
young self i said well we'll go first
three weeks later the in-app is business
journal and i have it at home it says
sets one billion dollar goal
wow um may 1992
we hit a billion dollars in sales five
years later wow
for the last you know 35 years you know
what i've been doing is i've had
coaches for skill training i've had
coaches and mentors
for mindset training i've had coaches
on brain training i've had coaches for
business skills and training i've had
coaches and mentors
and experts for every different
area of my life whether it's health
nutrition
business money investing getting out of
debt
making more money protecting your assets
there are experts for
every single area of our lives that
already know what you need to do
back in 1987 when i bought the
franchising rights for re max of indiana
um i had no idea how to build a company
i was you know 26 years old
and um but i had another mentor who i
invested
75 000 to become his partner to have the
opportunity to learn from this
man who at the time was worth probably
100 million dollars and so i was very
very uh keen on learning and i didn't
know how to build a business i didn't
know anything
other than how to sell real estate and i
set a goal
uh to uh generate one billion dollars a
year
in sales and i set the goal for five
years in the future
not knowing a billion dollar goal is
like
mind-boggling big for me and i
there was an interview um the second
week i was in indianapolis i moved from
toronto to indianapolis for this
opportunity
and um i was interviewed by the
indianapolis business journal and i said
uh in the interview that was at a goal
for a billion dollars and the
reporter said are you aware that there's
two companies that have been in the
state of indiana for
80 years 100 years the other one and
they haven't hit a billion dollars
in real estate sales in all of these
years and i said yeah i know it's graves
and tucker
and you can let them know that i'll be
the first
right and as i said that i almost felt
like i put my foot
right in my mouth because i didn't know
how i was gonna do it right
long story short five years later we
sold enough franchise recruit enough
agents
we did 1.2 billion dollars and we were
we were
stuck which is a great place to be stuck
and
i was asking myself how is it possible
that i'm
training these agents with strategies
with tactics with
selling skills marketing skills we were
like the gurus of here's the books
here's the cassettes here's the trainers
here's
like out of the deep end and the agents
who for example would make thirty
thousand dollars a year
kept making thirty thousand a year the
agents who made fifty kept making fifty
they
made a hundred kept making a hundred and
so i realized that
they weren't missing the skills or the
knowledge there was something else at
play
and what helped me from the age of 19 to
27 28
30 was every single day
and i still do it today i'll share this
with with you in just a little bit
every single day i was priming my brain
with the beliefs and the self-image
required to achieve the
goals that i want so when we talk about
reprogramming
i think the the important thing to
understand is 99.9
of what we think what we feel what we do
although
most people think i'm in control
i'm the one doing it it's really
non-conscious patterns
that are repeating themselves over and
over again so let me explain
when you and i were born the only
neural networks that we had were for
survival
right we didn't have any beliefs of are
we good enough
are we smart enough are we worthy we
didn't have
any experiences to show us that that's a
scary situation
that one's not snakes are safe or snakes
are dangerous or
spiders or heights or whatever the case
is so
over the course of the first seven to
ten years of our life
our brains plasticity switch our brains
switch that
connects all of these neurons and
creates the neural map in our brain
is is being created in the form of
millions of connections per second
by time we're 10 or 12 years old that
switch basically goes
off and now there's more selective
okay creation of neural patterns based
on what we
like what we dislike what we experience
what our parents tell us what our
teachers tell us up until that time
we're just an empty open nest
where everything's being formulated and
so what happens
is after you know 10 12 years old we're
pretty much running on autopilot
and we become conditioned or trained to
see the world a certain way
to feel certain things to behave in
certain ways
and so most of our life we're working on
autopilot because the non-conscious
processing parts of our brain
is working at you know 400 billion bits
of information per second and
trillions of electrical and chemical
reactions per second happening without
our thinking about it
and so for adults you know 25 35 45 50
we have these patterns that we have to
revamp almost like a remodeling of our
own brains
if you think about you know when you're
driving in a town that you know whether
you're at home or in your city that you
know and all of a sudden you see a
detour
if you take a detour and then you start
driving down
that new detour for a day seven days two
weeks three weeks four weeks
that detour becomes the new easy road
to take even though you're used to going
a certain way
the brain works the exact same way so if
you've got these patterns that are easy
for you
your brain wants to take those patterns
that are easy for easy thinking patterns
easy emotional patterns easy behavioral
patterns why
number one because it's less energy that
the brain needs to
to use so law of best use of energy in
the brain
is where it goes first so the way you
retrain your brain using for example the
4r
process is you recognize my patterns of
thought my patterns of emotion my
patterns of behaviors
and yourself are these going to help me
achieve the goal that i want to achieve
whatever the goal is
it's just yes or no if they are
great if they're not
then what you want to be doing is saying
okay how do i
change that path how do i change my
thinking
i'm learning that i could be still i'm
learning that i could
be aware of my thoughts but then let
them go and i come back to focus
on a sound wave in this particular
meditation
and then what happens is over a period
of practice
you realize that you're basically your
body disappears
you're no longer in this physical thing
you're no longer having these
waves of thought after thought after
thought after thought after thought
after idea
positive negative and everything in
between and
in that space of recognizing that
i'm not my physical body i have a
physical body i'm not my thoughts i have
thoughts i'm not my emotions i
have them when you start to train
yourself to use your
brain better more efficiently more
productively
you realize that a i am one with
this you know incredible universe so
what's the big deal about that
well the big deal is that if i am one
with this
universe with this energy with everyone
and everything
and that's where everything percolates
from
is it possible that all my answers are
right here right now anyway
and the answer is yeah and so meditation
is about
practicing and we know that we have uh
different brain waves so right now as
people are watching or listening
you know they're in this beta brainwave
frequency where their
brain is oscillating at a certain
frequency and there's 50 different brain
waves going on at any given time
but what happens is when i move into
from beta to alpha to
theta delta or gamma i'm actually
accessing and activating different parts
of my brain which now gives me
this deeper greater sense of awareness
of a much bigger you know onion that i'm
used to seeing so i'm living on a
layer of an onion and what if i could
see like 10 layers up and 10 layers down
all of a sudden it's like wow look at
who i am
what i am who you are what you are and
in that realization in that awareness
i can now start to have different
choice choices made and so meditation
is a practice of awareness it's a
practice of going
internal instead of external which is
where most people live their lives every
day
if you're going to be uncomfortable
your reward has to be big yeah i think
so
so if you're going to be making a change
ask yourself
why is what i want to achieve
so important to me why am i willing to
to you know use my new
willpower and persistence why am i
willing to go
through the discomfort of change why am
i willing to
you know listen to the negative talk
that i have or the emotion that i have
and still do it anyway and if you don't
have a big enough reason
the first time you have a chance for an
excuse you'll take it
and that's why people they start on
diets and after a day or a week or two
weeks they're off to diet
or they say you know what i'm not happy
my relationship
and you know two weeks later they're
back with the same person
or they find another person just like
the one that they left
or people are afraid to leave their jobs
um because they don't like the
discomfort of change yeah well
the only certain thing in the universe
the only
constant is change yeah every time
change everything that's the only
constant in the universe it's an
oxymoron
it's like how can change be the only
constant the only stable thing
because everything's changing so why not
acquire the skill to change every time
to be comfortable in change
and in today's era to be comfortable
within
in comfort yes yes yes and so
i know that the meaning that i give
remember i said you have to reframe
things
yes the meaning i give things now is
when i'm
uncomfortable i'm changing and i'm
growing and i go yeah
yes it's uncomfortable but this is what
i want
yeah right and then so we go through
these waves
of comfort and change comfort and change
and that's just like the waves of life
every morning when you wake up you have
let's say let's say it's 10 attention
units
if you're using two or three or four or
five or six of them on why you can't
whatever an attention unit is your your
ability to stay focused
and your ability to stay focused um is
happening at the conscious and
non-conscious level so if you're
processing stuff in the back of your
mind of something you're angry at
something you're mad at something that's
stressing out that
or you don't have enough money or you
don't have the right relationships or
the contacts whatever if you're
stressing out about that stuff and
that's eating up your attention units
that's like having your computer okay
using up most of its energy in what's
behind that you're not using
and we all have a certain amount of
attention units every day
and so one of the things that you asked
me before that i can come back on the
rituals
is is using the attention units in a way
that is
highly highly productive versus
wasting a lot of time and so my ritual i
mean we started earlier i just
remembered that
is you know wake up meditation exercise
of plant-based protein smoothie followed
by reviewing my goals
every day you remember every every day
five minutes the goals for the day the
month
every year everything i review my
overarching goals
i could do that fairly quickly because
that's my longer range goals
i can review the emotions that i want
because i'm committed to having those
emotions every day
and feeling a certain way every day and
then i take a look at from
you know you know five years out three
years one year
90 days 60 days to today wow
and so i just review it and whatever
piece of paper laminated and on my
computer
really yeah and i have it in a in a
booklet also so when i travel it's
really easy
do you have it with you no no it's it's
uh it's a pretty big gotcha
it's like a little manual you have to
send me a photo yeah i'll send you it's
called my exceptional life blueprint i
like it
and um and so the question many people
may ask is
why why would you do that well because
you're having 35 to 50 000 thoughts a
day
right and your brain isn't certain like
what's really important what's not
but if you instruct your brain that
something is really important whether
it's something you don't want or
something you do it will actually pay
attention to you
right so by priming my brain early every
day
here is what i want you to focus on here
are the emotions i want you to express
through me
here's the behaviors that i need to take
then i am
on a daily basis setting the course for
what i want my brain to focus on
i am cognitively priming the pump
and if i do it one day that's great if i
do it 60 days
100 days my brain goes hey i'm just
going to make this freaking automatic
because i want to conserve
energy right right i'm just going to
make it automatic so not only
will you focus on it consciously i'm
just going to make everything happen
behind the scenes to help
help you see think and feel things that
are congruent with what you're training
your life for
and what you want to achieve so i'm just
using the system better
on my my epitopes he lived he loved he
gave he had fun
i always thought that if there's a way
that i could somehow use my life
in a way that i can make somebody else's
life a little bit easier
to live either through knowledge or
understanding or
love or a process uh
then my life's been worthwhile and so i
just want to make i just want to make a
difference and
i'm one of the people that doesn't
believe that there's anything wrong
in the world everything's unfolding
exactly as it should
there are many things not to my taste
that i don't understand
but i just want to make the journey as
good as i can for as many people as i
can
when we talk about how do we create
rituals or how do we change
habits that last
the first thing is to have a different
expectation
than i'm going to change in a day or a
week or in 21 days
whenever i try to change anything
my number one rule is 100 days
or i don't even start so if i want to
let's say stop caffeine it's a 100-day
commitment
so first i make longer term commitments
and then i design a plan to retrain my
brain
around the expectation of
following through i make pre-commitments
in advance so if i say let's say i'm
going to stop drinking coffee
i say okay i'm going to stop drinking
coffee i commit to it for 100 days
and then i write out well what will you
do
in the morning when you wake up and you
want a coffee
what will you do when you're at a
restaurant with friends and everybody's
having a coffee what will you do so you
counter any of the behavior
when you know the trigger is going to
happen every habit has three parts to it
there's something that triggers the the
the emotion
there's the behavior and then there's
the neurological
biological reward so when you understand
the habit part of any ritual you
understand that
because we are conditioned a certain way
we're going to have a trigger whether
it's a flower whether it's
waking up whether it's a girl or a guy
or
or children coming home it triggers
a response in the brain or reaction in
the brain
well if we change the behavior over the
course of 100 days
we'll still get the reward and if we
pre-commit to what we're going to do
when we say
uh maybe today i'll have the coffee and
tomorrow i won't
maybe today i'll have the pizza or the
dessert and
i'll catch up tomorrow well if you
pre-commit in advance
that you're not going to take that
action then that's step one
step two is when you have the trigger if
you
interrupt the behavior for one or two or
three or four minutes you
interrupt the neural pattern in the
brain also
so you come up with strategies when i
feel like having a coffee or dessert or
the pizza or
the croissant okay then
here's what i'm going to do instead for
five minutes
and that way i can interrupt the pattern
if you do that
long enough you'll start to develop a
new
neural pattern you'll start to develop a
new behavior
and if you do it for at least you know
66 days but preferably a hundred days
you'll start to develop a new way of
thinking
and being and doing that will overshadow
the other pattern in the brain very
interesting yeah so there's there's a
there's a a psychology behind it but
there's also the neurological processes
of the brain and what happens
is our brain doesn't like change yeah
so any time that there is change
the brain see it feels uncomfortable as
soon as it feels uncomfortable
it'll send signals to the motor cortex
of the brain it'll send
messages and we'll start to rationalize
we'll start to tell ourselves well i
shouldn't do it because of this well
maybe today's not a good day we'll i'll
start today you know but i won't
continue until
next week or you know what i really
don't want this we start to talk to
ourselves
and when we understand what the brain
does whenever we try to change
then we can start being in control of
the brain and we can
override the automatic responses there's
something
called automaticity and automaticity
states that anything that i repeat over
and over and over again over a period of
time
will go from conscious effort
deliberate conscious effort will power
or persistence and it'll become
automatic so we just have to know how
long that is and some things take a week
some things take 60 days some habits
that people have for
20 30 40 50 years take 200 days
and so you start off with a 100-day
window and you ask yourself am i willing
to give a little bit of effort for 100
days
to remove this destructive either
thought pattern or
destructive behavioral pattern in order
for me to have something
greater and better than what i have
right now
so it's very important you you focus a
lot on what you will have or what you
who you will are who you will be in the
future
to keep your your motivation yeah if you
think about this one of the best
examples that i ever came up with is
imagine if i give you
a hollywood script right now okay
and i say to you um if you
learn this script for the next six
months
i will give you 10 million dollars to
be on stage to deliver that we're gonna
film you
and if you're amazing you're gonna have
a chance to win an academy award
what will you do with the script
starting today
i start to learn start to learn you
start to read it you start to
emotionalize it you start to practice it
you start to
you start to do everything possible
to become something that's in writing
something that came out of somebody's
head that they wrote a script for that
you don't have any idea what it is
but if you made a commitment to becoming
that
person and you rehearsed it and
practiced it
every day you wouldn't get it right the
first day
or the first week for the first month or
the first month
but if you knew there was a big payday
emotionally spiritually financially and
that people would go to the theaters and
love to watch it and they'd laugh or cry
or be sad and be happy
because you were able to take them on a
beautiful emotional rollercoaster ride
then you would become that role
yeah most people are interested
they're not committed and the difference
is when you're interested you do what's
convenient and what's easy
when you're committed you do whatever it
takes
can you repeat it sure when you're
interested
you do what's easy and what's convenient
for you
yeah but when you're committed i'm going
to get that result
you put everything into it until you get
the result
this is going back sometimes i think in
1992 we were stuck
but i knew there was more possibility
there was there was room for growth
and i wanted to figure out if the stuff
that i did
in the 80s when i was a kid you know
that broke free
would it work with some of my agents and
so we took
75 agents randomly agents said hey do
you want to get into a six-month program
to like retrain your brain your
subconscious brain
around your beliefs about what is
possible for you to achieve
around your habits of what you have to
do in order to achieve that
and we focused on retraining their
subconscious mind
and so for six months they had to go
through a process of listening to
certain audio tapes
reading reading certain materials every
day and following the process of
training their brain specifically their
subconscious brain
which controls 95 to 98 of all of our
thoughts emotions and behaviors today
and within six months that group
increased sales by
100 million dollars jesus
100 million dollars i said holy sh right
this is working
uh and so we started to teach some of
what we teach now in neurogym actually
now we have the technologies we have the
systems that are
far better than what we did back in the
90s and we went from 1.2 billion to 4.5
billion a year and it wasn't because we
taught them
any more skills to be real estate agents
we taught them
how to change the way they thought about
themselves we taught them how to
change their habits our agents who made
750 000
or more were in front of a client 75
percent of the time
and we asked all the agents that weren't
in front of more clients like
why are you doing that like why aren't
you in front of people
that are going to help you earn more
income oh well we're busy doing this and
doing this and doing this and they had
stories and excuses and
reasons why here's something you could
do quickly it's called a reframe so so
let's say you're driving in traffic
and let's say somebody cuts you off and
you've been sitting at the same spot for
you know 20 minutes like i did this
morning and somebody you know you're
you're maybe
looking down at your cell phone because
you have some time because you're parked
right and somebody cut you off so you
could automatically react go son of a i
can't believe he just did that and just
use
all of this energy the cortisol
epinephrine adrenaline that's flowing
through your body and causing stress in
your body
or you can say well what if that person
just found out their dog died they're
really trying to get home quickly
they go okay i guess it's okay if she or
he cut in front of me
right or they just got a call from their
mother their mother fell
yeah would you change the way you felt
about it and the answer is
yeah probably and the reason because you
change
the frame so you can learn how to create
frames for yourself how you see the
world how you see failure how you see
effort how you see your habits how you
create frames in advance that actually
serve you
through awareness and response versus
reactivity
and that is what a lot of people who
for example i'm going to go back to
professional athlete what do you learn
how to do
respond in a variety of different ways
in advance
or through practice yeah so that when
it's game time
you're just unconsciously doing what you
do there was actually
a very very big mistake in the movie the
secret
okay and in the movie the secret
the story that was told
was that all you have to do is think
believe in your heart
and you'll achieve it's not true
there's a lot of people who think
wonderful great thoughts
they believe that i deserve this and i
can have this
but they don't do one thing and this is
what causes their problem
you know what that one thing is oh you
want to know they don't
take consistent action every day
so in the secret they didn't talk about
you have to do the right things
in the right order at the right time
and they led a lot of people to believe
that all you have to do
think about it just think about it well
i've never met
a monk in a monastery who's been praying
to make money
and through the ceiling a safe falls
with a million dollars
i've never met that yet and but i have
met a lot of people who think
and believe and then they learn what
they need to learn
they upgrade their knowledge and their
skills they overcome their fears they
overcome their doubts they overcome
their lack of confidence they overcome
their lack of certainty
and they take action anyway and then
little by little things start to happen
for them they achieve the results
and we call that the law of goya g-o-y-a
get off your ass law of attraction
uh it's my favorite it's law
that's what works when it comes to the
you know the uh the problems that come
up every day
i mean it's it's like weather it's sunny
for a little bit
it's raining it's hailing it's windy
it's not
that's life and and that goes back to
where we started a little bit earlier
about the frames
is if you expect things to always be
great you're delusional
if you expect things to always be bad
that may be a little yeah that might
happen
um and so it's a matter of learning the
frames and how do you frame stuff so
even when you know i was going through
this challenging challenging times on a
lot of fronts
um the frame was still good we are all
creatures of
habit because habits run their
themselves their subconscious programs
just run themselves
most people don't take the time to
become aware what are my empowering
habits what are my disempowering habits
and then the next question is well how
do i release this one and how do i
strengthen this one or create a whole
new one and what we're looking to do is
build empowering
habits that then run run their course
we started to retrain our agents brains
after we did a
we did a an event 75 agents paid i think
it was
two or three thousand dollars to go
through a six-month brain retraining
program
those 75 agents increased our sales by a
hundred million dollars
wow and we said okay we're gonna teach
this to the entire company
yeah so we went from a billion two to
four point five billion in sales a year
in three years by working on this
versus what they needed to do what
you'll see is just patterns
patterns and more patterns the entire
universe
is made up of patterns that could be
explained mathematically for the most
part
but we can also just see behaviors
and so there it's not it's not
difficult but it's it's it's
it takes effort to be able to
override some of the natural
you know brains propensity the brain's
desire to keep us away from hurting
ourselves
to re-educate our brain yeah and if you
think about
you know when we have when we when we're
young what do our parents do well be
careful
oh don't fall down or watch out how you
ride the bicycle
you know and if you fall down well my
kids when you know when they were young
i let them fall and i let them do things
so that they would
get accustomed get up i wouldn't go and
and
and you know um baby them
they'd fall down i was like great you
fell down get back up they learned that
it's okay
yeah most kids when they fall down
they'll look at an adult to see well
is they gay or not it's okay or not then
usually the adults are either going to
baby them
and and over compensate or they're going
to look at them just come on get up and
and and you know do what you need to do
think about what is
a belief and let's go to again i just
like to go to the neuroscience fields
because just my passion now
is a belief is nothing more than a group
of cells
that have been connected and then
reinforced
and we have two types of beliefs we have
beliefs that whatever really fast i'm
going to stop you there because that's
so important yeah and so different than
i would have expected i think
when people hear belief it is believing
something that is true
which did not enter into your definition
no we we believe
whatever we believe is truth for us but
it's not
the truth that's really interesting
right but we have been conditioned
if we go back a little bit to um what we
talked about earlier about you know when
you were a baby
when you were born what belief did you
have
zero goose egg zero not one
and so you learned what to believe and
how to even
formulate your beliefs chances are from
parents
teachers brothers sisters television
maybe when you read some books right and
we behave based on what we believe
so we might be behaving our lives away
based on
false or inaccurate or disempowering
beliefs
so if a belief is a neural pattern in
the brain
then we probably have some good ones
empowering ones
useful ones and chances are we have some
that are not
useful not empowering and not worthy of
the geniuses that we all are so the
question is
is it possible for me to develop
new beliefs that i don't believe right
now the answer is yeah
when somebody tells me they've done
everything
usually they've done everything that
they're aware
of doing but there has to be something
if we go back to some brain research and
some brain
neuroscience findings there's a part of
the brain
that chooses the goal that we want to
achieve
and that's in the conscious part of the
brain and that's responsible about two
to four percent of what you see
and what you do yeah that's called the
explicit
memory system or the declarative part of
the brain i can declare
so i'll give you an example i could read
a book yeah
and ten minutes later i could tell you
what i've read in the book i can declare
everything that's in the book i can tell
you
you know what this is a great book i'm
so excited i'm so motivated
and i'm going to make a million dollars
but if at least if
at the implicit level at the beneath the
conscious
mind at the implicit level in secret
they say i don't know if i'm good enough
i don't know if i'm smart enough i don't
know if i deserve to make a million
dollars
i don't have the right knowledge i
didn't go to college
i'm male i'm female i'm too young i'm
too old if there's a
disconnect between the implicit
the part of our brains that's the real
you and me the hidden part of our
self-image
if there is a contradiction
between my goal and even what i've
learned
and what i secretly believe to be true
by myself if there isn't the coherence
between the two
the hidden self-image will always win
so one of the most important things is
to create
what i call is neural coherence or
coherence in the brain
and the best way to think about
coherence in the brains imagine
if you know you go to listen to
a band rock and roll band jazz band
a classical band whatever and
every player okay or every musician is
playing the music
but not in harmony yeah new style you're
never going to have
a beautiful symphony so the way our
brain
works is if we don't have the symphony
at the different parts of the brain
we'll do some
good things and some good actions and
then we'll do some
things that will take away from that and
so what we want to have is
is coherence get the brain
the implicit and the explicit part of
the brain coherence
playing together in harmony
then moves the body into action
consistently
now we have flow now we have
a way for us to take our ideas
and take action consistently to achieve
results
an hour a day to upgrade your mindset
and your skill set one hour a day
is all you need to set aside to upgrade
your beliefs
your habits your attitude your
perceptions your emotional management
and upgrade the skills that you need in
order to
play at the next level of success so if
you calculate one hour a day is 365
hours in a year that equals nine
40-hour weeks nine forty hour weeks
after one year you're really good after
two years you're
really really good after three four five
six years of doing this every day
just upgrading your knowledge and skills
with expert information
and knowledge and and strategies and
tactics
you are in a whole different place in
your life
so invest one hour a day to
upgrade your mindset and your skill set
so your action set what you need to do
becomes automatic instead of
something you have to consciously try to
do
every day because mindset plus skill set
plus
action set equals your results
i've just come through a really
challenging time i was in business with
one of my very best friends of 30 years
and we started a company together in
2006 or so
and he ended up with severe diabetes
and had a stroke and had a heart attack
and
it went you know everything just went
hell in a hand basket
lost lots of money lots of employees we
had about 70
plus employees we let them go close the
company down
i had friends of mine who put 2 million
into the deal
i put a couple million dollars into the
deal and it was
you know all my intellectual property
they developed over six years was
basically
held up in a legal lawsuit that i had
with one of my shareholders and
investors
and it was a very challenging time wow
there's this
you know reputation ip start from
scratch
um assets association shows everything a
lot so it was
challenging very very challenging time
and uh fortunately because of you know
my meditative practices staying staying
aware of what
is not buying too much into that i just
you know started building a new company
over the last uh four years and i've got
you know 30 amazing team members now
our company at neurogym my relationship
my wife is great my kids are awesome my
health has never been better i became
vegan about
five years ago stopped drinking alcohol
seven years ago gave up sugar about
three weeks ago
let me know how long you keep it up i
made a decision now it's a year so the
one year one year one year no no sweets
yeah no refined sugar if it happens to
be there have to be honey on
you know on something that a little bit
is fine but no refined sugar no cookies
no cakes no chocolate bars
no soft drinks nothing well right now i
don't have any cravings whatsoever
zero wait till the holidays true you
know what i just came back from montreal
and and i was there for the holidays and
the dessert table was about as big as
this
and i just said no and a week before
actually four days before that i was in
las vegas
at encore at the buffet and i actually
took a video of
everything that was there and i said now
what i did beforehand is i pre-committed
when i before i went to las vegas i said
now when i go to the buffet here's what
i will do when i
go to this restaurant here's what i
would just i pre-committed in advance
played it over in my mind 10 15 20 times
put myself
in the situation in my mind and then
when i was there it was
easy breezy because i'd done it you've
visualized 10 20 30 times
so i did that and so when i went to
montreal usually i go to montreal and
all hell goes to lose my mother
you know is always good every day she's
not anymore my sister's taken over oh
yeah so the uh you know the food that's
there and um
and the desserts that are there
breakfast there too i love poutine oh
yeah yeah
but the desserts for me is was the
hardest part but it was like easy breezy
i own my feelings and my emotions and my
results
i own my feelings my emotions and my
results
i learned how to be responsible
to be able to respond to
emotions that are unpleasant to feelings
that are
you know yucky i learned that whatever
was happening
in my world i had
the ability to upgrade my skill
so that i can use everything that
happens in a way that
serves me as opposed to a way that hurts
me or
moves me back so mark waldman in his
um little training over here says
seven days of gratitude exercise the
more you focus on your thoughts the more
your brain becomes habituated to it
the brain the brain tends to pay more
attention to negative thoughts
this is based on the instinctual parts
of the brain
we can train ourselves to focus on the
positives as well
at the end of the day he says write down
three things you feel grateful for and
three things you did well
this can change your brain you only have
to for seven days and you will see your
self-esteem
grow for three months so when we are
giving you
you know uh gratitude things to do
anything we're teaching you to do
it's all based in neuroscience research
and so the more you're grateful the more
you have to be grateful for
the more you train your brain to be
grateful
the more it looks and becomes habituated
to look for
other things to be grateful for that's
why i want to show you there's einstein
which represents our left prefrontal
cort
cortex the the smart genius
part of our brain that has imagination
that can come up with all the ideas of
what about this what about this i can
have this i can have this
but what most people don't understand is
we also have right a
frankenstein part of our brain the inner
critic
you know it says but you're not good
enough you're not smart enough what if
you fail what if you're embarrassed what
if you're ashamed
so we have this you know that's why i
have them there's einstein
and there's frankenstein just to remind
me and to remind my students
that both exist within us and
our goal is to understand that you know
the way our brain works is
there's always a protective side of our
brain so frankenstein's always going
what if you fail what if you succeed and
fail what if you disappoint yourself and
einstein's going
don't worry about it imagine the future
and so there's this constant battle in
our brains
you know going on in our goal and
meditation is one of the best ways to
recognize that both exist
and both are right your frankenstein
part of your brain is there to protect
you
your einstein brain is ready to help you
achieve your goals and dreams
and the key is remember you're not your
brain you're not the einstein part
you're not the frankenstein part
there's another side of you that is much
greater than
all of it i thought i was afraid of
public speaking right
i thought that was oh i would just say
i'm a bad public speaker that was my
story
well you're absolutely right when you
said that's what it was i was afraid of
judgment i was afraid of rejection
and that was what was holding me back
and these are subconscious patterns
right so the feeling okay is this
uncomfortable which is very
uncomfortable it's it's stressful
it's it creates anxiety and so it's not
the public speaking
so the question is where did you learn
to have this idea that speaking
in public causes you to be embarrassed
ashamed ridiculed or judged
and here's what a lot of people will say
if you ask them like where did that come
from
they'll say well you know when i was a
kid in class
and you know the teacher asked the
question and i answered
and the answer was wrong you know the
other kids made fun of me
or the teacher said no that's not the
right answer and
and and you know they were embarrassed
and the other kids ridiculed them and so
like who
wants that so if our brain
is focusing on wiring whatever keeps us
safe
and whatever keeps pain away
we avoid pain or we'll do anything to
avoid pain
way before we do anything to gain
pleasure and so
survival first avoidance of pain second
before we gain pleasure so if there's
any
real or imagined danger where we're
gonna be
emotionally hurt mentally hurt
physically hurt financially hurt
our brain gives us the signal be aware
this may be one of those
times it says be aware this may be one
of those times
and so the the cycle the neural circuit
the cycle shouldn't stop there
but when you people haven't been trained
on here
are my six core emotions here are my
feelings that those emotions cause and
here's what to do when
this emotion is triggered do this
when this emotion is triggered do that
and what you want to do is learn
when the emotion of fear is triggered
the
neurochemistry is adrenaline cortisol
epinephrine norepinephrine that's like
this high anxiety
rocket fuel within us now in most people
it caused them to just stop put on the
brake
but how is it that a firefighter
okay could could see a building blowing
up in front of them a building crashing
down
a raging fire and yet she musters up the
courage to use
that fuel from fear and go in
it's because she's been trained yep
that's because she's been
trained there's a misconception
that business is easy and
i have a lot of clients of mine for
example that are there are doctors and
lawyers and professionals
that have an expertise in a certain
area but nobody's ever taught them about
finance
about legal if they're not a lawyer
about marketing about sales about
technology
about operations about management and
being an entrepreneur is like solving a
rubik's cube
yes i see that right so you can have the
two by two
with two colors you know it's easy if
you want a little bit bigger business
that's three by three there's more
combinations and more things that need
to be
considered four by four now has
billions of different moves just four by
fours
billions of different possibilities wow
when you get to the
eight by eight or 16 by 16 rubik's cube
there's quintillions of possible moves
that you can make
so building a business is all about
recognizing patterns and knowing
which move to make at the right time
and there's four options that you have
one is
do it yourself and try and figure it out
two is get help
three get it done for you or four don't
do it
did you know that some of the most
recent studies on
setting goals and writing them out or
typing them out on your computer
will actually increase your chances of
achieving those goals by up to 42
percent
why well as soon as you put the energy
to writing out your goals and getting
clarity
you're giving your brain the instruction
that this is what's important to you
this is what you want to achieve so
don't be
like all the other people where they
have goals and dreams and they hope and
pray for it to work
be the type of person who sets her goals
or his goals
in writing and then focus on that every
day and you'll achieve
more of your goals if you don't
understand
that every brain has an error detection
mechanism within it okay what is that
any time you veer out of your comfort
zone the fat
point setting or the financials anytime
you veer out of it
the first line of defense is self-talk
that's negative
that's the first thing that pops up
because your brain is going that's not
true
so it's detecting an error between what
you said as an affirmation or even what
you just visualized or even what you
just
did against the predominant neural
patterns
that exist so it's an 800 pound gorilla
initially fighting the flea
right dan heath's book and so what we
want to do is we want to get the
the conscious goal the vision aligned
with a non-conscious pattern
and as soon as you align that you have
neural coherence and when you have
neural coherence
that's like hearing your most favorite
band
playing your favorite song and you're
just like
oh that's the best blessing it's just
bliss
if it's not bliss you're out of
coherence and so the key and why we
start off early with meditation is
awareness of how do i tune in my
vibration
how do i let go of that unempowered
self-talk that sentence that thought
that i had or that disempowering it's an
unpleasant feeling beliefs aren't good
or bad
they're only pleasant to unpleasant at
varying degrees
when we're at a coherence it's
unpleasant unless our
life is on the line and safety is there
for the most part you know a fear of
failing where's that coming from we've
failed our whole lives successfully yeah
but the meaning that we're giving you
know uh what people will say what people
think
you know how i'll be embarrassed or
ashamed those are all the things that
you need to
really get in tune with every level
of success that you want to achieve in
health
wealth relationships career business etc
requires
a new understanding of a skill
and a new behavioral pattern what got
you to where you
are is not enough to get you to where
you want to go
why do i say that because if it was
enough to get you to where you want to
go
you would already be there
so what got you here will not get you
there maybe some stepping stones
but every level of success
requires a new level
of skill and behavior and i'm going to
go
back to one of the other lessons since
we develop
beliefs and habits and behaviors
that go from conscious effort to
non-conscious
habits in order to achieve the next
level of success
you have to learn how to create new
habits of thought
new emotional management skills and new
behaviors to
match the level of success that you want
to achieve
because i felt dumb
i read thousands of books and did
hundreds of courses and
because i didn't feel like i was smart
enough
i took the thing that could have
i guess made my life a mess and turned
it into
my fuel for success and because
i lived with parents that didn't have a
great marriage
i ended up divorcing twice
but because of all of those things
i studied and researched and
and dove deep into who do i need to be
to have a great relationship what
communication skills must i have
um who can i model that had a great
relationship
i'm afraid not to do it now
so people ask me like when do you stop
never
when when they bury me is what i'll stop
i am i have such a habit of working on
me
learning more becoming more more loving
more caring more kind more generous
more giving more like where do you stop
and it's not a matter of of acquiring
more
i'm not going to eat any differently for
the rest of my life
than i eat now you know i'm not gonna
eat bigger
you know meals i'm not gonna do things
too much differently than i am now
so now it's a matter of expression and
expanding more to do more good in the
world
so in order for me to do more good in
the world i have to expand even my own
mindset
i've got to get away from the fears that
i have
of maybe not being good enough or not
being smarter i still get those feelings
but because of my daily rituals and my
daily practices
i get back to my spiritual center my
spiritual core
and a little bit more confident and a
little bit more certain every day
towards the goals that i want to achieve
and i bridge that gap
and then when i reach those goals keep
doing it again
you all know that you have a
conscious part of your brain
that's responsible for certain
things okay but then you also have a
subconscious part of the brain
subconscious and so what
is this 800 pound gorilla
that prevents you from achieving your
goals like what is it like
what do you think it is about the
subconscious
that prevents you from achieving your
goals when consciously
you want to achieve your goals right
consciously you want to achieve your
goals and
okay camiar yeah we have you know right
hemisphere and left hemisphere of the
brain
and in between okay we have something
called the corpus callosum
that connects both hemispheres and
contrary to popular belief we're not
you know left brain dominant or right
brain dominant we use
all of our brain uh every 24 hours so
you don't use only five or ten percent
of your brain
um the possibilities are endless
all right but when you're talking about
the gorilla
the subconscious is is the you know what
i what i talk about in the book
right is i named it the gorilla so
conscious and subconscious yes and so
tell me what you know about the
subconscious mind like
if it is the 800 pound gorilla what do
we know
right the gorilla gets what the gorilla
wants
and so if you ask yourself a question
of do i really know how
to get my subconscious mind
aligned with my conscious desires and
goals
so answer that question for me answer me
that riddle
do you know how to get your subconscious
mind by the way the subconscious is not
like
here and the conscious is here we know
that
the left prefrontal cortex for example
is the seat of you know awareness and
it's the seat of decision making it's a
seat
of choosing what we want we know that
this part of the brain we call the left
prefrontal cortex
and it's what i call is the einstein
part of the brain
it can figure things out you consciously
can figure things out uh the right
prefrontal cortex
is the pessimist or what i refer to as
the frankenstein part of the brain
that moves into the memory system and
brings
forth anything that may uh get you into
trouble anything may be painful
anything that might hurt you
and so there's these these things going
on in the brain if you think of your
brain as an
orchestra and some
of your brain um
is responsible to play certain pieces
and other parts of your brain are there
to protect you
when those pieces uh oppose each other
or are not in alignment then you
have chaos
the fascination that i have is um
around living in a world right now where
we have
access to all the how to
how do i make more money how do i grow
my business how do i have a great
relationship
how do i you know find the love of my
life how do i
put a rocket ship on mars and
a lot of people are confusing having
information and how to
with actually doing it and
i've been fascinated just in
understanding how do
i help people unleash more of their
potential that already exists
and a lot of people may have heard you
know they say that we only use
five to ten percent of our brain that's
not true we use a hundred percent of our
brain's capacity neural networks
every moment of every day but
the potential to use more
is there and so our researchers at
neurogym
really are uncovering how to take the
best information from the world of
neuropsychology
neuroscience and give it to everyday
people so they could say okay how do i
overcome my
fear of not being good enough my fear of
not being smart off my fear of
being embarrassed or ridiculed or
ashamed or fear of
failure or fear of success these are all
psychological issues that
everybody feels but very few people
understand
when i feel that what do i do about it
so that i can unlock
more of my potential so i can actually
take more action
first on the things i already know that
i
could be and should be doing but i'm not
and next on the behaviors that i could
be taking
to achieve my success easier and faster
and that's really
my my passion is helping people unlock
that amazing potential within them
when i was 19 years old okay
when i had a mentor a man who was in his
50s very very successful
he agreed to to mentor me and to teach
me what he knew
and so he sent me home with some paper
and on the paper it said what do you
want to achieve in your health
what do you want to achieve in your
relationships what do you want to
achieve
financially what do you want to achieve
charity
what do you want to achieve as far as
experiences
when do you want to retire by how much
money do you want to make
how he asked me about 10 pages of
questions
and at 19 i i had no idea
how much do i want to make i want to
make enough to pay my bills
i want to make enough to you know just
eat well
and then have some fun i want to go
drinking with my friends i want to go
party and travel a little bit and
pay for my apartment than a nice car and
things like that
but he had me think you know one year
five years 25 years and i was 19
and he made me write down the
answers to these questions even though
they were
i had no idea how to achieve them he
made me write it down it took me a whole
weekend
and i went back and he looked at my
papers
and so he looked at health and wealth
and relationships and career and
business
and he goes good way to do the exercise
i'm very proud of you
he says now i want you to increase
that amount and so i said that you know
by the time i was
45 i was 19 i said by the time i was 45
i was going to be a millionaire nobody
in my family
was a millionaire not my aunts not my
uncles not my cousins nobody
in the area that we lived in and i wrote
that down
and he said no that's not enough he says
you can do better than that and i'm like
i'm swallowing i'm scared i'm afraid how
am i going to become
more than that how can i have all of
this he says don't worry about the how
right now
you worry only and not even worry but
you write down what you
want and so i went back home
and started to write again and and took
another
you know half a day to to redo my goals
and he said to me great now in order for
you
to achieve those goals what do you have
to believe
wow i said well i have to believe that i
can
i have to believe that i deserve it and
even though i didn't believe that i
deserved it
she said what would you think you had to
believe
i have to believe that it could be done
i have to believe that i could learn
the skills i would have to believe so he
made me write out what i would have to
believe
good question and then he said great
what do you think you would have to do
every day wow an amazing question
well i guess i would have to come to
work every day and i'd have to
really get good at what i'm doing and
i'd have to learn more that i'm learning
right now because i hated to learn back
then
and i'd have to you know gain more
skills which i
didn't have any the only thing i was
good at
was i had an easy time talking to people
like i am with you now
and he said great well let's make a list
of all of these things and let's come up
with a plan
to do this he said so every day let's
look at some beliefs and so every day he
would have me look
at my goals and i would sit in my chair
and i'd have my goals you know that he
had me right
and i would take my fingers which he
told me to touch my goals so that i
would send a message to my brain
as i was reading it and seeing it to
reinforce
the goals that i wrote then i would read
the beliefs that i needed to have
i have all the intelligence i need to
achieve these goals
i can now acquire all the skills
to achieve these goals and i read about
20
or 30 different beliefs every day
and for the first month or two months
while i was reading all of this in my
head
this one word kept coming up you know
what the word was
because as i would read it my brain
would say
[ __ ] that's not true and he told me
that my brain would try to talk to me
and tell me it's not true and he said if
you keep doing it over and over and over
again
your brain is going to get tired of
telling you it's not true
and especially if after you
do this you take some actions
to upgrade your knowledge upgrade your
skills
you'll develop more confidence and more
certainty
so he taught me how to use the telephone
to make telephone calls to people to
see if they were interested in buying a
real estate property or selling their
home i was in real estate at 19.
and you know for the first month it was
hard second month it was hard the third
month it was hard but as i got
better and more comfortable at being on
the telephone
talking to people that i didn't know
that i thought didn't want to hear hear
from me or talk to me
i found one person then two people then
three people
then five people who said yes
because as i became more comfortable as
i became
more skilled as i gained more knowledge
people received me differently and in my
first year
i made thirty thousand dollars i was
nineteen
which was five thousand dollars more
than my father made as a taxi driver
then he started to upgrade my skills a
little bit more
and he started to teach me some very
specific
things to do in real estate and in my
second year at 20 i made 151
000 wow five times more income because
every day for one hour one hour a day i
practiced my beliefs i
practiced seeing my vision i
rehearsed it i got on the phone i
upgraded my knowledge i upgraded my
skills i love your story
thank you and and so he kept he kept
directing me a little bit at a time
to become more tomorrow than i
am today and he said to me something
that changed my life
it says if you invest one hour a day
[Music]
on your personal growth and changing who
you believe you are
that is the equivalent of nine
40-hour weeks of effort
one hour a day for a year is nine
40-hour weeks if you and i said today
we're gonna learn
break dancing we're going to learn
knitting and we're going to spend
nine weeks 40 hours a week
we would get good at what painting we
would get good at
admitting we would get good at darts we
would get good at playing a musical
instrument
if we were committed to one hour a day
so i've
practiced one hour a day for
32 years
and that one hour a day has changed my
life
so crap board so um vision board for
seeing what you want
um the accomplished board for reminding
yourself that you've got a lot to
uh that you've accomplished so you feel
good and the crap do you actually put up
images of things you've accomplished
uh-huh yeah yeah i have them in my
closet
in my home uh encased uh
on the floor like on the floor so that
you
don't look at them so you know i look at
it no so i look at them just because i i
sit down and put on my shoes
i want to look at them every day
interesting yeah on my um
i have i have this ritual as well i do
something called brush and prime
so on my bathroom mirror
i have my goals that are on my mirror so
that as i'm brushing my teeth i'm
priming my brain
to see my goals in front of me every
morning and every night i love that
right so that's priming your brain which
is a whole other topic we can have
and then the accomplishment boards
reminds me whenever i look at the stuff
that have accomplished i go
that wasn't easy i mean there was a lot
of ups downs highs lows failures
you know times i thought i'd quit and i
didn't so it's to remind me
to go through the times that i don't
think i'm gonna be able to achieve those
things
and then the crap board stands for
conflict
resistance accomplishments
and procrastination so what conflicts
are are happening right now that i need
to resolve
what resistance is in my way is what are
my resistance what in front of me is
resisting right now and then
accomplishment as well is to remind you
that
you can get through stuff and then
procrastination
is what's causing me to procrastinate so
if you create a crap board as well you
have that in front of you
and then you can create a game plan for
what am i going to do about it what am i
going to do about the conflicts
if you think about what makes up who we
are
so obviously there's genetics there's
our genetic makeup so our predisposition
our propensities
and that makes up a percentage of how we
see the world and how we show up
but then the rest of it we're trained on
so we're trained to see the world the
surgery so there are certain people
that have something called the
negativity bias and the negativity bias
is nothing more than
they see the negative first it's not
that they don't see the
positive but they see the negative first
there's other people who see positive
first they have a positivity bias then
they
see that first and the truth is in
almost every situation in every
circumstance
there's both you can train somebody
to recognize that there's always both
just like
every inside has an outside every one
side of a coin has another side of a
coin every up has a down
that's called the law of polarity and in
the universe that we live in
there is that law of polarity and so you
can teach somebody say okay if you're
propensity if the way you
naturally are is negativity bias first
great be aware of that then flip over we
call it flip the switch
so if one side of your brain is going
negativity first
great learn to flip the switch go great
what's the positive side of that
that's a skill you can learn no
differently than playing tennis or
chess or music when you sit down to
meditate do you
come with an intention then each time
no i i i um when once i sit down
then i ask my intuition hey
what is it that you want to be doing
today
what is it that you need today so we all
have this intuition which is different
than our
instinct but this intuition right it's
what we know before we think
and so when i sit down and say okay
um hey what's what's the intention for
today
and sometimes the intention is to just
let go and see what happens
sometimes the intention is i'm searching
for you know for an
answer uh sometimes the intention is
well today focus
you know today let go today just breathe
so i just listen i just it's just it's
it's the
the art and the subtle science of paying
attention the key is to really
understand
first and foremost that you have
a brain you're not your brain
the whole idea with inner size right
is to create um a pathway for you
to be able to say okay here's how my
brain works
simply as i've put it today and here's
what i could do about it
to move out of a state of chaos and
dissonance
and into a state of coherence
and alignment so when you were born
were you born with any beliefs no were
you born with any habits
no were you born with any fears no
no so from a neuroscience and
neuropsychology perspective a belief is
nothing more than this
imagine that you're born and your brain
is made up of a hundred billion marbles
and every time you have an experience or
somebody says something to you read
something
or you watch something these marbles
make these connections
and the connections that are reinforced
go from
conscious connections to subconscious
connections
and once these subconscious connections
are made and reinforced
they run the show 98 of the time so a
belief is nothing more than a reinforced
pattern
in the brain and our conscious brain can
choose what we want when we're in that
part of our brain but our subconscious
mind can't
choose its program from the age of zero
to three
uh in the imprinting years three to
about seven or eight the modeling years
and then eight on as the experiential
years
and so if you have these uh powerful
beliefs that you're good enough you're
smart enough you're
worthy to achieve the goals that you
have um if you have these powerful leads
if you are able to achieve any amount of
income you choose no matter what the
amount is you just need to learn how
so if you have these empowering beliefs
you have brain coherence between
conscious and subconscious
we are in in a society that just goes
goes goes goes goes goes goes
texts emails phone calls facebook
twitter vine all these things are
keeping us on this perpetual hamster
wheel
of doo doo doo doo doo the very few
people stop
and say what am i doing what am i not
doing
what am i thinking what am i feeling
so the first part is stop second part is
to
reframe it's called the four r
process recognizes first reframe
is the way i'm looking at something and
because we are mono focused the brain
can not
focus consciously on more than one thing
at a time
all right it can get distracted to that
thing then this thing then that thing
then this thing
the art of multitasking is actually one
of the worst things that you can do
from a neurological perspective highly
successful people are able to
mono focus on the right things so when
you learn to reframe
your brain's ability to look at this
then look at this
then look at this but stay focused on
what it is that you're looking at you
see
different perspectives of it the next
part
is to release the emotional
stress that most people's brains are
under
how do we get into this emotional stress
well when we
have fears there's 50 different types of
fears
fear success fear of failure fear of
disappointment fear of being embarrassed
fear of being ashamed fear of being
ridiculed
fear of fill in the blank when our brain
goes on these
automatic fear circuit drives
then we're in a state of fight or flight
in a state of fight or flight
over a course of a day a week a month
our ability to actually use our thinking
center the left prefrontal cortex of our
brain actually diminishes our brain gets
hijacked into this fight or flight
response system over and over and over
and over and over again
and that response system is actually
pretty healthy initially to get you
going and out of the gate
but if you are always in this fight or
flight response mechanism
you're on this hamster wheel you
actually start to get burnt out
and you can't think you can't use the
genius part of your brain
you can't really activate the part of
you that connects to the entire universe
of
intelligence within you and outside of
you
and so you learn to release that tension
to be able to put the foot back on the
gas change the gear
if you think about what happens when
you're driving a stick shift car
you put your foot on the gas in first
gear and the car just goes
but if you keep your foot on the gas in
first gear you're going to burn out the
engine
so what happens in the release part of
using your brain is you go from first
gear
pause second gear pause third gear pause
you're able to use the engine more
efficiently to go
faster exact same thing with our brains
if we learn how to release the tension
and
switch gears release the tension switch
gears that's the art of release and go
and that causes the fourth r and that's
we retrain our brain
to operate at higher levels of our
intelligence
genius and abilities what happens
if at the subconscious level okay so you
have conscious
goal conscious vision conscious reasons
why i want to achieve it
what happens if at the subconscious
level
let's say for weight you've tried to
lose
weight before and maybe you have but
then you've gained it back
what if you've done that three or four
or five or six times
is that pattern okay the memory the
pattern
locked in the subconscious mind of all
those experiences
is it there here's how the brain works
you set a goal using the left prefrontal
cortex of your brain your
imagination and then right after you set
the goal
and you're excited because you're you're
making some progress
your brain says hey um
last time you did this uh you gained all
the weight back
why even try uh last time you did this
and your friends saw that you did this
and then you gained all the weight back
next time you saw them you were
embarrassed uh you were a little ashamed
of yourself
last time you did this or the three or
four or five or six times
before that you gained all the weight
back
and you disappointed yourself and your
significant other because
you know they said you looked really
great and then you gained all the weight
back
so you disappointed them uh and yourself
and you were embarrassed or ashamed um
and so
that pattern is there right do you all
agree with me
so far the pattern is there and so if
you have
and think about your imagination and
your your your
choice to set a goal is one pattern that
you
formulate but if underneath there's a
subcon
there's a subconscious pattern of
embarrassment
shame failure guilt disappointment
etc if that pattern is also there
then you have two opposing patterns you
have one pattern that says
let's go and do this but you have
another pattern that says but
last time you did this you failed or
you've seen your sister or brother
or mother or father or friend do this
and guess what they gained all the
weight back anyway so
why even try i'm going to keep you safe
in your comfort zone i'm going to
conserve energy and that way i'm going
to save you some time and money and
energy
does that make sense to you that is
called cognitive dissonance
that is another way of saying that's
called chaos in the brain
and a brain in chaos will do what
it'll just stick around doing the things
that it's comfortable doing
where it's known something that i
learned that i think people will
benefit from is an anxiety attack
stress panic ulcerative colitis
all of these things are effects
right so they're effects so the question
is
what's the cause yes right so most
people are
focusing on either you know suppressing
the effects
depressing the effects um
masking the effects they're doing
everything but going
what's causing this and if we look
at the world of cause whether it's in
our physical body
whether it's our relationship whether
it's our bank account whether it's our
business
whatever the result is every result
in the physical world is an effect
so the question is what causes the
results
and one of the greatest laws in the
universe is the law of cause and effect
and it states that for every
effect there's a cause and for every
cause there's an effect
and so i got really inquisitive and
curious
early on with can i control
more of the cause of my results
and that required responsibility and
when i was younger
it was like i was more into the blame
game it's because of
him because of her because of it because
of the market because of where i live
because of my mother my father how old i
am or how young i am how
asian or [ __ ] asian i am it doesn't make
a difference so
a lot of my upbringing
caused me to look outside of myself
and when i looked inside myself
and took the i guess the
prerequisite of responsibility i own it
yes i can change it that transformed my
life that you know that really started
to
put things into perspective if you think
about
visualization is simulation
now here is the difference whoa that's
good
okay go ahead so visualization is
simulation so
when we close our eyes or even if our
eyes are open and we start to use our
einstein
brain the imagination we now have just
activated one of the biggest centers of
our brain the occipital lobe that's
connected to the motor cortex it's
connected to
the motivational circuit the nucleus
comes that releases that dopamine that
makes you feel good that makes you want
to take action
so if you visualize yourself
achieving the goal if you visualize
yourself behaving in ways that
match the new belief if you even
visualize the words
or you take the words on a sheet of
paper
and you read them run your right finger
across it run your left finger across it
close your eyes
see it and feel it your brain is
creating a mental movie with the words
and as it creates a mental movie with
the words that's happening in your
subconscious mind
and when you give the subconscious these
instructions a couple things happen
because of the way the brain hierarchy
works number one it's survival but then
number two is safety
and then number three is energy
conservation now when you do something
20 30 40 50 times it takes about 66 days
to 365 days of
repetition to override an old habitual
circuit not
10 days not 21 days 66 to 365.
so if you visualize yourself achieving
the goal
feeling the success that you want to
feel seeing the belief
on the screen of your mind you are
actually creating a neural network
through the science of neuroplasticity
and the networks that you reinforce
become the most dominant networks
and since your brain wants to conserve
energy
if you do this on a consistent basis
your brain says okay
you're doing this so often let me just
make this automatic let me set aside the
old beliefs let me replace it with the
new beliefs
and now you've deliberately and
consciously evolved yourself
one of the things that is is really
interesting i mean just based on what
you said
there is something in business whether
it's for sales people on the phones or
sales people in person on the phone it's
called
call reluctance and in person
it's pull it's called contact reluctance
and so if you think about what does that
mean
so i have a call reluctance i have a
reluctance to call somebody that i don't
know
and so when some people think about
calling somebody they don't know when
they're prospecting or meeting somebody
they don't know
if you think about what is it that is
actually happening that causes them to
to feel that so as soon as they have the
thought their
neurochemistry kicks in because the
meaning that they have
is if i call somebody that i don't know
and they hang up on me they yell at me
they say something nasty to me
then they are attacking my identity
and in most cases they have associated
the attack on their identity
in a negative way such as
well maybe it's true that i'm not good
enough maybe it's true that i'm not
smart enough maybe it's true that i'm
not worthy
so they have a negative association with
somebody's response that they don't even
know
about who they are so the first thing we
work on is let's focus on your
self-esteem because it's the self-esteem
that's being attacked
my self-esteem and self-worth is being
attacked so when my self-esteem and
self-worth is being attacked
in a negative way or unpleasant way
i'm gonna process that as danger
in my brain now when you understand the
brain's number one responsibility is to
move you
away from danger or pain that's number
one on its hierarchy of
how it behaves so if there is
real or imagined pain or discomfort
your brain says stop put the brakes on
go the other way
that's what's happening so the first
thing we do is we teach people number
one
let's change the meaning that you have
around what somebody else's response is
around who you are or what you're doing
or what you're offering them
so the first thing we work on is change
the meaning you change the feeling
the beautiful thing about the time that
we're living in now
is we can share knowledge and
experiences
and anybody with a you know a phone
an ipad or smartphone or an android
or a computer anywhere in the world in
the kalahari desert in
antarctica can get access
and get inspired it's the best ideas in
the world yeah to get the best ideas in
the world
but to see that we're no different none
of us are different
the illusion is that we're different
because we're comparing
who we are compared to the person that
we're
listening to or learning from we're
seeing the gap
and the gap is what causes us to be
uncomfortable but if we remember
we're all spiritual we're all made from
the
exact same thing you know
if you think about the human body it's
made of hydrogen oxygen nitrogen
carbon helium there's there's elements
but we came from the furnaces of stars
you can't have carbon okay in the human
body
that didn't come from the inside of a
star
helium and hydrogen is what the big bang
was initially made up of
and then as all the gases coalesced and
created stars and then galaxies
we became our flesh and blood and
everything that we became the organism
has come from the universal intelligence
that's why we're all connected
and that's where we all have the same
abilities different skills
different knowledge but the same
abilities to become
all of the ideas goals and dreams that
we have
and so we just have to say that is what
i want to trade my life for
and even though i don't know how even
though i may not feel totally
comfortable or confident
or i'm lacking certainty let's get let's
get on the path
and then we can change the world
together if everybody can imagine for a
moment you're driving a car
and everything's going great and all of
a sudden a light pops up on your dash
now the average person won't take a
hammer and hit the light to turn it off
an average person will take a look at
what is that light am i low on
windshield wiper fluid
am i low on air in my tires is my back
trunk open what's going on so just like
the signal in a car is meant to make you
aware
fear is a trigger in our subconscious
mind
that real or imagined danger
has percolated in our brain
and so fear there's nothing wrong with
fear we can actually use fear
as fuel now i like to you know give
people
visuals so imagine if you have you know
two parts of your brain there's many
more but imagine these two we have the
einstein brain
and we have the frankenstein brain and
when fear gets
activated let's assume that that's our
frankenstein brain going
what if what if you get hurt
what if you lose money what if you die
what if
you get embarrassed ashamed ridiculed or
judged
and so where why does frankenstein even
get activated because we're not born
with those fears
and so if we're not born with those
fears that means that
something in our brain is triggering
this reaction
automatically without our thought and
that
is what we call is the fear response and
we also know that that fear response
causes something called the sympathetic
nervous system to activate
which causes us to want to fight freeze
or run away that's just the absolute
reaction at a biological level
of what is happening now when we want
to deactivate that sympathetic nervous
system there's several what i call our
inner sizes that we can do
that actually gives us more control more
power
and the ability to reactivate the
einstein part of the brain so
inner size number one is really really
simple
it's called take six calm the circuits
so as soon as you
catch yourself in a state of uh
doubt fear worry anxiety stress
that means that frankenstein's activated
if you just took
six deep breaths in through your nose as
slowly as you
could
and then you exhaled as if you're
exhaling through a straw
in your mouth
if you just that did that six times that
very simple inner size
would deactivate the frankenstein brain
and allow you to reactivate your
thinking
imagination einstein part of your brain
and then you can do the second inner
size which puts you right back in
control
and that one i call is i aia
which is now a matter of awareness
awareness of my thoughts
emotions feelings sensations or the
behaviors
that i've just taken or the one i'm
afraid to take
and in a pure state of awareness without
judgment blame shame guilt or
justification
let me repeat without any judgment blame
shame guilt or justification
of the feeling or the thought of the
behavior now i'm empowered again because
now i can observe
and now in this observational mode i
could say okay what's my intention
let's say for the next 10 minutes well
my intention is to be happy
great my intention is to be productive
great my intention is to
you know take action on this one thing
that's going to help me towards my goal
and dream
so in the awareness and in the intention
then if i say what's one small action
step
i could take towards what i want instead
of
what i don't want so all of a sudden
i've
interrupted a fear pattern i've created
this state of awareness i've set an
intention and now i'm taking
action towards what i want versus
being paralyzed by what i don't want and
a fear that may or may not be real
so awareness is what actually gives us
choice
and choice is what actually gives us
freedom if we make the right choices
we all have these patterns
that are subconscious that are
driving our behaviors more than
our conscious efforts and so
when we're dealing with the gorilla
in the brain and again it's a
metaphorical way to look at it
you have to understand that the gorilla
is going to get
whatever the gorilla is wired to get
the gorilla does not care about what you
consciously want the gorilla
really focuses on the patterns that are
going to keep it
safe and here's what safe means safe
just means comfort zone
let's say you're miserable let's say
you're broke let's say you're
overweight let's say you're in a
relationship that you you don't like
let's say you're a job you don't
love that is
safe to the gorilla why because it
knows the pain it's already dealing with
it knows the discomfort
it knows the price it's paying already
versus getting out of that comfort zone
leaving the job that you're not happy
with leaving a relationship that you're
not
in love with um trying to earn more
income getting out of debt you could be
in debt
and comfortable you could be in a
relationship you hate and comfortable
you can be in a job that you
don't love and comfortable and the
gorilla
is gonna keep you in your comfort zone
for the people who think that the law of
attraction is
um you know think believe and you'll
achieve first i'm going to tell you that
so let's call it i love this man
um but i want you to think of your brain
just a little bit differently and think
of it this way let's say you love
rock and roll and let's say rock and
roll's on
station 95.5 if you're on station 92.1
that might be classical
if you're on station 98.7 that might be
punk rock but at 92.5
that's rock and roll so imagine
coherence just means
locking your electromagnetic spectrum of
your brain
lock it and load it on exactly what you
want
so what's the vision what's the goal
what are the beliefs
what are the emotions that create
coherence
so you're locked and loaded to the
frequency of the universe
that is matching that goal part one part
two
is when you get locked and loaded you've
actually activated the einstein brain
connected to the motor cortex connected
to the dopamine release in your body
and when that happens okay now you're
in coherence but there's another part
that happens in this einstein part of
the brain
that's actually what the latest
neuroscientists
psychologists are thinking is connected
to this gps
part of our brain to the frequency of
where
all of the tools resources people are
that resonate with
that frequency so
we've been evolving for what two and a
half million years since homo erectus to
now 108 billion humans on earth
with a brain that's been changing and
growing
and my belief is we're just scratching
the proverbial
surface we talk about you know little
quantum mechanics or quantifies with
entanglement how we're all connected
we're all
tuning into the frequencies that are us
and within us and all around us
now when we learn to use our brain
better uh
it's just mind-boggling how we can
achieve goals and dreams that we thought
were
impossible to achieve before i have a
philosophy that
every moment every precious nanosecond
and moment
is perfect and so when i connect to the
perfection of that moment
there's really nothing to do it's to be
aware and to allow
to surrender but not to give up
surrender
but to understand that you know as you
know we're talking right now
the oceans don't need any instruction
what to do
the uh the um planets that are moving in
in their elliptical orbits around the
sun don't need yours or my intervention
the universe the milky way galaxy that's
you know flowing through the universe at
a million and a half miles per hour
doesn't need yours and my instruction so
that means that
every moment is perfect so i want to
connect to the perfection
of every single moment be aware of that
every single moment
and realize that many things are not to
my taste many things i don't understand
but that doesn't mean that the moment
isn't perfect
what if you said okay i want to make
let's just say a hundred thousand
dollars a year or a million it doesn't
make a difference
and i asked you what do you need to
believe about yourself
to achieve this so i need to believe i'm
smart enough good write down
i am smart enough what else do you need
to believe i need to believe that i am
worthy i need to believe that i deserve
this i need to believe that it's
possible i need to believe
you write down five or six or seven
beliefs that are just words on a sheet
of paper
now let me stop for just a moment i'm
going to tell a story and come back to
this i want you to imagine
that somebody tapped you on the shoulder
sometime today and say hey
i work with steven spielberg and tom
hanks in hollywood
and we have this new script okay
that if you get really good at this
script where you could read it in front
of a camera without the script
we'll pay you 10 million bucks now i
want you to imagine you've never seen
the script
you don't know how to act but they said
to you we're going to give you an
acting coach we're going to give you
everything you need to memorize the
script
we're going to do everything you need to
act it perfectly what would you do
to take that script that's on a piece of
paper that you've never seen before
what would you do to take that script to
make it
yours for you to own it and the answer
is you probably read it like what once
would you read it maybe 100 times 200
times 500 times
you think you might role play with
somebody while you're holding the script
in your hand
do you think you might research the role
do you think you might take a camera and
practice it
and you think that if you practice it
one time 50 times 100 times
500 times you can finally put the script
down and you can get in front of the
camera
and go boom here is the script do you
think you could do that well guess what
a script that's on a piece of paper that
you don't believe with practice you
start to believe
so what happens if you take a belief
system
and you start to imprint it into your
subconscious mind initially through
conscious
repetition but there are ways to access
the subconscious mind that we know today
that are faster and easier than just
doing it consciously
and so you take a vision of you
achieving your goals and dreams you take
the beliefs you need you
learn how to manage your emotions a
little bit better and then you develop
the habits which again
are nothing more than neural patterns in
the brain they've been reinforced
and when you learn how to deactivate the
destructive ones
and activate constructive ones through
space repetition and reinforcement
now you are resetting your default way
of being
so a belief is nothing more than a
reinforced pattern
that if you learn how to deactivate it
and create a new one
it's like a software upgrade for your
brain
all we have which everybody talks about
is this this moment this this precious
second right now so the more i could be
here right now um
the more i'm living you know my um the
life that i want to live
i don't want to be too much about the
future too much about the past i can use
those as something to
you know hope for in the future as a
guiding post from the past
um but right now is the moment that
every one of us has
any event that's occurred in the past if
you just
merely think of that event that's
occurred in the past
chances are you're firing off the neural
network
of that pattern right so you can take
um uh the idea of eating your
favorite dessert what do you think is
happening in your brain
when you pretend you're eating that
favorite dessert of yours
and your mouth starts to water and you
start to feel oh that's such a great
dessert
that's neurons in your brain firing in
the neurochemistry
that is associated with that memory
firing
now let's say that you
have a disempowering pattern of being
embarrassed or ashamed or ridiculed
but instead of just thinking about the
pattern oh i don't like it
as soon as you think about the pattern
and it has a
i'm going to say a disempowering or
negative emotion
chances are that means that the stress
center
in the brain has been activated that
means that your heartbeat is going to go
up that means that your sweat glands are
going to be activated
that means you're going to breathe a
little bit less
deeply you're going to be more shallowly
and that is the
fear or stress response now what if
instead of allowing that to continue you
just
stopped and you had
this intention i'm going to
dissolve the effectiveness
or the strength of this pattern how do
you do that well first
and foremost you stop you sit and you
start with
inner size number one that actually i
guide you through
in the book all right and inner size
number one is called take
six calm the circuits so you want to
move from your
stress and react system
to your relax and respond
system you have parasympathetic and
sympathetic nervous systems
okay that are triggered within the body
so what happens when you sit quietly and
you take six deep breaths in through
your nose
and out through your mouth like you're
blowing out through a straw when you do
it
six times in ten second rhythmic breaths
and you focus on the air that you're
blowing out through your mouth like
you're blowing out through a straw
that simple inner size
is inner size number one take six calm
the circuits it actually
deactivates the stress fear
embarrassment shame guilt circuit
and in a quiet relaxed state
that same memory does not have the same
power
but if you don't do it in that state you
do it in a in a tense
stressful state you're actually
reinforcing that pattern
versus thinking about bringing up that
old memory and doing this repetitively
10 times 20 times 30 times 40 times
until the neurons really don't fire that
strength
at that strength level the stuff that
i'm fascinated with is
behavior right perception and behavior
is how i see myself
and how people see themselves and why
and then how they see the world
and why and then we know that
the action i mean you know in the secret
you mentioned earlier i was in the
secret and
the thing i loved about the secret is it
gave people some hope that
changing my thinking really can make a
difference but there's also the other
part of it
you know the law of attraction there was
one thing that was left down it was
called the law of
goya and the law of [ __ ] is the g-o-y-a
law it's a get off your ass
is nobody that i know other than trust
fund friends
okay that haven't had to do any work to
achieve their success
nobody that i know whether it's tony
shea whether it's you whether it's me
whether it's mark cuban whether it
doesn't mean richard branson oprah
winfrey doesn't make a difference
they've all had to take actions but it's
not just any action
it's taking the right actions in the
right order
at the right time consistently and so
i've been fascinated with how do we help
people develop the mental
emotional and behavioral
habits that lead to success
because that's the key mindset skill set
and action set that's the formula
i have my vision boards and i actually
have my exceptional life
blueprint that i've created it's about
50 pages
of my prayers my rituals uh for my
spiritual growth health wealth my money
story my intermission my outer mission
you know some of the stuff
you know either that i have or that i'm
creating
and so i create these visual
representations to trigger the biggest
part of my brain
called the occipital lobe and to
activate my memory center
so i have vision boards for what i want
to create so i'm giving my brain
the exact instructions so that not only
it focuses
helping me achieve that but most people
don't understand about vision boards or
creating
goals in writing that are specific is
that your brain
is a deletion and distortion
tool as well so if you give your brain
instruction of this is the stuff that's
important to me for health god
spirituality charity fun experiences my
children my mother my father myself
whatever it is
and you say this is what i want to trade
my life for
delete and distort everything else now
all of a sudden you're using your brain
as a deletion of distortion organism
in order to be able to help you hyper
focus on what you want
i got really inquisitive and curious
early on with can i control
more of the cause of my
results and that required responsibility
and when i was younger it was like i was
more into the blame game it's because of
him because of her because of it because
of the market because of where i live
because
of my mother my father how old i am or
how young i am how
asian or caucasian i am it doesn't make
a difference so a lot of
my upbringing caused me to look
outside of myself and when i
looked inside myself and took the
i guess the prerequisite of
responsibility i own it yes i can
change it that transformed my life that
you know that really started to to put
things into perspective
i tend to be a goal-seeking
guy right and i used to not celebrate
the small stuff and i just just like you
know find a bigger goal bigger goal
bigger goal more bigger bigger
and somebody says to me like are you
gonna like slow down just to enjoy
some of the stuff that you actually have
done for yourself and for people in your
family
and i was like well uh let me create an
accomplished board
oh good so good right
so accomplish board you passed that test
on your own
40 years ago celebrate that
you helped this person who was
challenged and celebrate that
you know you did this for him or for her
or for yourself
celebrate that stuff to remind yourself
because i i'm tough on myself like i'm
let's come on let's go it's a goal let's
go
um and sometimes i forget the stuff that
i
have done the stuff that i do do that
i need to remember so i created an
accomplishments board and a list
so i can just go to it when i feel like
holy [ __ ] am i am i smart enough to
achieve that next thing am i good enough
what a lot of people don't know ed is so
good when i was a kid i used to feel
like i wasn't smart enough
and when i was a kid it held me back and
today i
still feel like i'm not smart enough and
that fuels me to get smarter
so i use it like i said big goals like
oh god i don't have
the skills i don't have the knowledge
but i can figure it out
i've got contacts i've got friends and
there's books there's google there's
there's
youtube there's holy mackerel i don't
need to have all the specialized
knowledge anymore
let's say you have
a shortage of money right now
let's say you're not earning as much as
you'd like and there's too much
month left at the end of the money
too much month left at the end of money
creates stress
uh decisions around money can create
stress what to buy what not to buy is it
too expensive is it
you know not expensive enough for my
taste whatever the
the the the stress is um i want you to
understand stress a little bit
differently from the from the brain
perspective this is the um part of the
brain
the the brain stem that is
attached to the first part of being
called the reptilian brain which is
connected very very quickly to the
amygdala the stress response center in
the brain
when we have stress in our life whether
it's
money stress emotional stress
relationship stress business stress
career stress whatever stress we have
the signal that is sent through
the electrical system in the brain and
the chemical system in the brain
when stress is activated there's a part
of the brain called the vagus
nerve and the sympathetic nervous system
which is part of your autonomic
nervous system but the sympathetic
nervous system specifically
is the system that activates the stress
response system
activates one of four things
fear okay um and when
and we'll talk about fear in just a
moment but when we're in a state of
stress
the fight or flight response kicks in
the sympathetic nervous system so when
we're in a fight
mindset we are we are using a lot of
epinephrine adrenaline cortisol and
there's this
current of anxiety now
that's not that bad if it's a little bit
but when it's too
much it actually deactivates the
thinking part of your
brain that can actually solve the reason
you're stressed
so when we are in this fight or flight
which is runaway modality
or the freeze or faint modal there are
people who freeze when they're under too
much
stress there are people who faint under
too much stress there are people
um who who run away and there's people
just try to fight it
so when we are looking
at the brain and we're looking at stress
okay this is what heidi's talking about
here she says stress
is our own gps system saying that
something is out of alignment
and the energy movement from the
common respond part of the brain is gone
to the stress
and react part of the brain and so
one of the the tools to calm
the brain down to go from reactive
stress
to relax and respond is
inner size number one that we teach and
that you're all going to be able to uh
learn in my new book called inner size
but inner size number one is called take
six calm the circuits
so whenever you're feeling stressed
whenever there's a problem whenever
you're feeling overwhelmed whenever
you're feeling confused whenever you're
feeling like
it's too much stop as opposed to
trying to fight your way through it stop
calm down close your eyes
take six deep breaths like this
in through your nose gently in a rhythm
of about
um six breaths per minute every 10
seconds
and when you do a breathing exercise
take six calm the circuits that's inner
size number one
you actually deactivate the stress
response center in the brain
and you activate the calm and
respond part of the brain highly
successful people
whether they're taught it like we teach
it or they just know how to do it
automatically they do it they feel fear
and then they release that fear and they
take action anyway
so they can turn their fear into fuel is
one of the
things that we teach people how to do
turn your fear into your fuel
and when you turn your fear into your
fuel in a calm centered
way you now are able to use that
neuroelectrical chemical called
epinephrine
or cortisol the stress hormones
and use them to fuel your success faster
and easier than ever before
you just reminded me of something
something that i learned that i think
people will
benefit from is an anxiety attack
stress uh panic ulcerative colitis
all of these things are effects
right so they're effects so the question
is
what's the cause yes right so most
people are
focusing on either you know suppressing
the effects
um depressing the effects
masking the effects they're doing
everything but going
what's causing this and if we look
at the world of cause whether it's in
our physical body
whether it's our relationship whether
it's our bank account whether it's our
business
whatever the result is every result
in the physical world is an effect
so the question is what causes the
results
and one of the greatest laws in the
universe is the law of cause and effect
and it states that for
every effect there's a cause and for
every cause there's an effect
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the question of the day i
wanna know what was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of action
for the next week when you watch a video
and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down in the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you there's something that we teach
called cognitive priming
what's cognitive priming first and
foremost
we know that each one of us has 35 to 50
000 thoughts a day and those are just
random
thoughts that are happening within our
brains and
not only are we having internal thoughts
which is different from thinking but
just thoughts just
neurons firing thoughts we also have an
enormous amount of
influence from our external world you
know people trying to get at us whether
it's
advertisers whether it's friends whether
it's whatever it is there's enormous
amounts of information coming into your
brain
so your brain is consistently analyzing
deleting and distorting what it needs
what it doesn't need for survival first
and for you to achieve whatever it is
you've become
comfortable achieving the patterns run
your life
so why use a vision board why
look at your goals every day why
emotionalizing like why because
your brain is really really really smart
in some ways let me explain
if you take some time every day
like every morning before you go to bed
every night
to say hey here's what i see myself
being doing accomplishing
if i do that every day then i am priming
my brain
to focus on what it is i want it to
focus on
now visualization is one of the best
ways
known to access the non-conscious
operating system of the brain and if you
do that on a regular basis and you see
yourself you develop the pattern in your
brain
first the brain
then looks for things in the physical
world
to match the pattern if you want some
incredible
tom bill you motivation check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you're going to study until you
fall asleep you're going to
push and push and push and then you're
going to push
more and when you hit the limit you're
going to push again beyond that you're
going to force yourself into an
adaptation response